[Music]
hello my people
my friends
welcome it's monday you know what that
means another
week
full week
baby of the h3 podcast four
episodes
coming at you
uh today's episode by the way it's
august 22 a beautiful beautiful summer
day cooled off a little bit here in l.a
thank god
uh but uh hope you're staying cool and
having a beautiful summer today's
episode is sponsored by hellofresh
this summer make all your meals easy
breezy
with hello fresh you get fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and recipes
delivered to you every week
get 16 free meals across seven boxes
plus three gifts
with code
h3tv16 at hellofresh.com
h3tv16 look at those scrumptious meals
man
love hello fresh
thank you for sponsoring us and also
brought to you by uh
babel and honey so thank you
well
i'm sad to say wow why is this sound so
awful
that sounds like kind of a miscorrupted
super loud too though
what yeah
zach is gone zach is gone for the week
he's on vacation and he's gonna be
sorely missed a b
whose idea was this for a b to sit in
front yeah [ __ ]
what do you say was that waka flaka yeah
okay
yeah is it too loud it seems too loud
yeah flocka
all right bro what are you doing
we're good
proceed
yeah so a b is going to be you're going
to be feeling it all week for him yes
sir yeah it's going to be an adventure
okay excited whose idea was that uh that
was mine
right
can you prove that dan
um
i thought originally it was gonna be uh
like we would have like a rotating uh
guest star in that role oh that's
interesting but a b seemed determined so
you want it for the whole week
all right well let's see how you do
uh that was thank you waka flocka
everybody
[Music]
well
welcome
welcome welcome
you know i want to talk about right out
the gate first of all how's everyone's
weekend everyone had a good weekend yeah
pretty good
pretty good a little a little tired did
the whole like bachelor party thing this
weekend what you had a bachelor of
someone's bachelor party
friend friend not yours right not mine
an old old old friend that would have
been a surprise if you were having a
bachelor party oh yeah
my wedding's next week i didn't let any
of you know because none of you were
invited so what did you turn up at the
bachelor party
a little bit not that much to be honest
but i'm definitely sleep deprived and
maybe a little hungover i think i'm okay
actually i think it's just like what was
the craziest thing you saw this bachelor
part here [ __ ] we
killed a drifter
dude seriously that is pretty crazy yeah
fun man good times yeah that is crazy
yeah
we [ __ ] killed him dude that
definitely fits into my uh definition
there of a crazy weekend
um i want to talk to you guys about
house of dragons
game of thrones is back
i went in there
ready
for a flop i am i'm telling you the
wounds have not healed still from that
last season of game of thrones which was
so
painfully is the worst [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
and there's moments during this new one
house of dragons if you guys don't know
it's the pr it's a prequel to game of
thrones it premiered last night on hbo
the first episode was perfect bro
exactly what i want from a game of
thrones the pacing was awesome
the characters are sweet the dialogue
the character development was great the
world building is great i'm all in good
actors too really good actors
so
it's kind of interesting because game of
thrones was pretty much all
for the most part unknown actors who are
now mega famous now but when it started
nobody knew the [ __ ] they were like
jason momoa i don't think anyone knows
who that guy was before game of thrones
no that definitely blew him up everybody
is uh
spamming no spoilers right now in the
chat i'm not spoiling anything i i know
i wouldn't do that to you why would i do
that to you yeah
you know me you know me better than that
just saying it was good
yeah but
chill bro you guys
no faith
anyway i thought it was 10 out of 10. i
liked it so much 10 out of 10. i liked
it so much i made an imdb
account so i could give it a 10.
really ethan yeah i did that
because i was just so happy you know
i was a super fan of game of thrones i
read all the books
i was super into the whole thing
and i can't express to you just how
[ __ ]
gutted i was by that last season i mean
i've talked about this at least but it
was just so
such a betrayal of everything everyone
invested in
well those two idiots that made the
first one are [ __ ] gone they're not
involved they're not involved and what's
great actually is that with the new one
george rr martin has more control
he has more involvement that's what i've
heard
via the contract i suppose
but uh i gotta tell you guys this is it
man this is it
i'm gonna oh yeah current imdb rating is
9.1 thank you that was me was at nine
when i made my account
such a good first step did anyone else
watch it i did
did you love it
i wouldn't say it was 10 i i feel like
you're what was bad over selling it no
i'm not i didn't think it was
there was nothing wrong with it dan
i didn't think it was a particularly
compelling pilot oh my god it's well
executed here here's what i'm basing
that off of
it feels george r martin's
executive producer dan go ahead right
that's great
um
no i i'm not saying i didn't like it i i
enjoyed it i'll probably be watching it
but uh probably okay
well we'll see i got to see more
episodes i don't know it uh
just comparing it to the pilot of the
original game of thrones which is like
so good at hooking you and like
immediately wanting to like see more
you're you're speaking from nostalgia
that first pilot of game of thrones was
not that good it was slow as [ __ ] bro i
disagree it's not about being slow it's
about
the story threads that it sets up and it
was good but the thing is if you only
know that first episode is great in the
context of the rest of the season right
like i agree that first second the first
season was amazing of game of thrones
that whole first few seasons were
incredible you only know it's great in
the context and i'm saying i disagree
i think that that's why i'm saying that
the original pilot for the original show
was better than this pilot because
do you forget spoiler alerts for the
[ __ ] first season of game of thrones
for whoever has not seen it yeah you
know that episode that pilot ends with
the revelation that the brother and
sister are [ __ ] and then they kill
they kick but who you think is the main
character up to that point well they
don't actually kill him but they kick
him out of the window or whatever that's
that's like a way to like give you a gut
punch at the end of the episode this
this new one
it feels to me like a new season at game
of thrones if like i i can't imagine
somebody watching this show who doesn't
know game of thrones yeah you have to
know the lore but well is that my
problem but that's why i'm saying it's
not as good of a pilot it doesn't like
stand on its own merits like you have to
know
i don't care about that i don't care i
don't care about merits okay okay again
from my experience i loved it it was
awesome and i can't believe you're
downplaying this for the people watching
you're you're potentially depriving
people i would give it like
good rating i'd give it like a seven or
eight out of ten it was it was good it
just wasn't like wait give it to eight
let's say seven and a half compromise
okay that's fine i'll i'll i'll uh
people say oh
it's not hipster to say that i thought
it was pretty it is he's being
contrarian oh my god i ran a poll uh wan
is winning people just want to say when
people just like was saying wang dan man
w dan
olivia just said now i want to watch the
first game of thrones pilots see me just
i don't want to say that just my
description of it has her hooked whereas
if i were to give a plot summary of what
happened in that episode last night
you'd be like i guess that maybe sounds
good well it's it's also i'm going to
never i'm not giving any plot points
because i'm not spoiling it right and
that's why i have to kind of tiptoe
around it but so how are you gonna be
like oh i described it is so good but i
can't even describe the pilot
maybe i could describe it and people
wouldn't watch mine maybe
you want to give it a shot did you have
you watched it no i haven't no which is
why i'm more compelled to want to watch
that one i think you and i are the only
ones that watched it so oh my god
this is all you got to bounce off a baby
right here well i i the thing is like i
love the first show but they're honestly
the
the first show is fatally flawed in that
the whole
[ __ ]
show is building up to this cataclysmic
event the whole thing
and
when they finally end
like yeah they were following
the author's book which is great
and once the book
the the book is not finished so once
they
went past where the book was
it just went so
[ __ ] to [ __ ] like i can't tell you
man it was just so
disappointing
oh
it's just so hard they're calling me lan
lannister which i believe
isn't that actually a character lan not
that i know of no i think it land
lannister i'm pretty sure that's like
yeah land the clever it's the one that
is like tyrion's like kind of
hero or whatever oh he's like the old
day the old yeah yeah he's not actually
in the show but he's like somebody
they're referring what lan oh my god
land land
land the clever was a legendary trick
whoever came up with that heroes they
know the deep lore they know the deep
house lannister boasts descent from him
through the female line according to
legend land the clever swindled casterly
rock from his previous rulers there you
go
okay
[Laughter]
anyway i thought it was great i thought
it was great i loved it and i think it's
going to be good too the actors are
awesome i read a review of somebody in
the media that had previewed the whole
season and they said what they got that
yeah the media don't tell me that i
don't want to know anything about the
full season
i don't care i was going to say
something
they were saying it
that it
takes its time but they said it the by
the end of the season it gets pretty
wild and and compelling so why do you
care why would this person even write
that i feel like even that's a spoiler
that i don't like that it's good like
how no you go oh it takes its time okay
that's a spoiler and then you say oh the
end gets crazy and it's worth like you
know who watches the whole series and
reviews it after one episode that's
black for me
who the hell who what
it's a spoiler
oh my god
it tastes like beef jerky
what
thank you it was just something worked
about that
[Laughter]
but uh in truth um
i'm excited for it it's been a long time
since i've had like a show like that i
personally liked my favorite parts of
the game of thrones is when they took
their time to pace things correctly and
develop characters which is what the
first season was so i think i consider
that a good thing
um
oh and lord the ring starts next friday
okay
yeah they timed that pretty well didn't
they
feed them to the punch time to feast we
feast in
uh these next couple months
yeah that one i'm gonna watch it don't
get me wrong and i mean it's amazon
prime so we basically all get to watch
that show for free
jeff bezos
but they spent like two billion dollars
on it or something yeah to budget it's
like the craziest budget ever
i think it's gonna probably
suck
but
hopefully not
yeah i want i
i don't want to say it because i don't
want to i don't want to manifest it
because i would like for it to be good
but
yeah
go in with low expectations that's kind
of exactly and hopefully it's amazing
and everybody and it's the best show
ever i hope so as well
because they're they're drawing from the
best source material there is
but it's not easy to as we've learned
there's been so many lord of the rings
um
um
[ __ ] what do you call it when adaptions
for for television or movie that were
not great
took a long time before they got it
right with the modern one
yeah they
it was when i heard the reports that
they kept peter jackson far away from it
that i was kind of like
that seems
seems a little weird
but you want they did they didn't want
him involved
well he did make the hobbit
well i guess that's true kind of lost
credibility they did
dude made three movies out of the
[ __ ] hobbit yeah
yeah
no he lost his he lost his uh
his clout with the hobbit man that [ __ ]
sucked
uh each episode of lord ring show
was 50 million an episode yeah
let's go
why are these kids what what also i
guess
i guess [ __ ] starving kids bro
lord of the rings well this is more
important than that um
the dudes
show running the lord of the rings show
they they have like almost no credits
like they they they haven't done really
anything that notable before yeah that
makes sense just give a ten billion
dollars into some random come up
it's a little weird it's a little weird
and that's that's part of why i don't
necessarily have a ton of confidence is
like who the [ __ ] are these guys but i
don't know it doesn't mean it's
definitely gonna be bad but no no it
doesn't well the game of thrones guys
were unknown dudes when they were
relatively unknown
but obviously i hate their guts [ __ ]
hate them
not the best endorsement
but anyway yeah it was great i loved it
and i'm excited uh that it's back
one kind of funny thing here
i saw this on reddit check this out
so many people were watching the game of
thrones premiere this whole look how
many people are watching it in this
building
how awesome is that they're all like in
sync
very curious to see what the
ratings are yeah look at that there's
like half the rooms are watching that's
pretty nuts
love that
what when
i just said that's wild how many people
are watching i'm curious what the
ratings are gonna shake out to be for
that premiere
i mean i think a lot of people are
hesitant because of how [ __ ] the last
one was
but i it seems like the the um
consensus is that it was good
here this is the imdb for one of the two
guys uh producing the lord of the rings
show
flash gordon
that's announced that's not even
something that's out
so whose dick did you suck to get this
that's what i'm saying like getting 50
million dollars an episode to make this
show with like no
background you would think that they
would
give it who wrote it that's what i'm
curious about
who wrote the [ __ ] that's what oh god
what show runner means uh a head writer
essentially in tv well and they're
directing too
uh yeah oftentimes the show runner will
direct some episodes usually in tv
though each episode has a different
director because it's too it's too much
content for
i see for one man yeah like game of
thrones same thing usually
oh my god dude oh my god
i can't believe what's happening okay
i'm just hoping that they wrote this
incredible screenplay that they just
couldn't pass on
that might be good
it might be good i want it to be good
i'm not hoping for it to fail but
oh there was one scene in the in the
premiere it's not really a spoiler but
i'll say
there's one scene where they mention
kind of the events that happens
this is a way [ __ ] bigger spoiler
than what i no it's not bro
this is something specifically that
happened in the episode but it's i'm not
ruining a plot point i'm just trying to
make a point all right
they mention um
that like
basically the events of what happens in
the
old one
i'm not going to say it i might spoil
something but
it was just made me it made sure they
said that it just makes sorry
it just makes it hard to
forget how shitty the last one ended
stop it right now people are saying
better call saul you know i'm not caught
up with that show sorry guys
zach says it's
the best show ever
yeah i mean
yeah no it was really good i've watched
like three seasons of it i liked it
so i don't know
wait and or what the hell is that what's
the next star wars show oh is anybody
watching that [ __ ]
you know everybody had the same reaction
when we were talking about it that like
oh cool you made a star wars show about
the the hawkeye of the star wars
universe basically um i watched the
trailer
it looked okay i don't know
i don't i ain't got no space in my arm
for this [ __ ] yeah i'm pretty over the
star wars uh universe at the point but
the trailer looked decent they have over
saturated the star wars market like oh
my god i hope they they got their
money's worth from that purchase dude
who cares about this character a rebel
that we know dies i don't understand the
intent with this show he had a small
role in rogue one well they're really
trying to [ __ ] make
they're just milking the [ __ ] for
content dude yeah
i saw today that they announced a
documentary about the making of the
obi-wan show too yeah no they really are
just it was okay it was pretty good we
don't need a documentary
jesus christ disney
oh the rehearsal i did watch
you guys all been watching the rehearsal
yeah behind
i finished it i'll be honest as a huge
diehard nathan fielder fan nathan for
nathan for you is one of my favorite
shows ever
i thought the first episode was genius
and super funny and the longer it went
it just became less funny and more weird
i agree ending with the last episode
that made was just honestly sad and made
me very uncomfortable me too and i loved
it
really yeah but there's like a real
child that like got [ __ ] with i don't
get that yeah
it was devastating it was like please
i just didn't really understand why they
had to do that
well he i mean
they just went with what was happening i
don't necessarily think that they knew
that that was gonna happen at all but
like that is such an interesting
storyline
that they monopolized on you know
like
that's
i don't know i don't know i i don't want
to like give it away
if we talk about it but
excuse me i thought it was bomb you know
what you guys aren't going to hate this
i i i better not even say it about the
rehearsal
because it's going to insult a lot of
people
but just suffice to say you know i think
it wasn't funny and it was just plain
weird
and like i get he was following the
thread but it's like
i think he just lost control of the show
i mean
seems like it just stopped trying to
even be funny at a certain point
but there you have it my opinion on that
the boys i love come on you know that
that's like the best show ever somebody
said patrick mckay who's the guys who's
imdb i just pulled up that's doing the
lord of the rings
uh was making a movie with ryan
cavanaugh no shot called goliath
no [ __ ] shot dude that is brian
cavanaugh is a foreign that's true he is
a force of nature thank you harvey
weinstein john d payne that's the other
guy yeah sure enough he had a
david and goliath movie in development
with uh ryan cavanaugh relativity
studios yeah uh
yeah the rehearsal olivia you said that
there's uh some speculation that it's
not real
and i also had uh some sneaking
suspicion of that too that it just was
way too [ __ ]
yeah i totally thought that
all the way through until
after i finished the episode i realized
that was the end of the season
dude i think the first episode of the
rehearsal was the best that one felt
real to me
yeah that one was the funniest
by far i thought all right we're not
talking about shows anymore people are
saying stop spoilers and you know listen
there's a lot of good stuff to watch
that's the good news
right
also
at the top of the show by the way we
have a great show
taint was absolutely destroyed which
we're going to be celebrating here today
he has lost everything and i love that
for him
cancel me i do not care i don't care
okay well
he was on uh aidan ross stream begging
for forgiveness wasn't he no one can
damage me
well um you do get banned on pretty much
every social media i don't even have a
[ __ ] account where your new banned me
i don't even have an account yeah that
you think that's slick because you get
all these little boys to post your [ __ ]
but i don't think they're going to even
allow that anymore
you know i exist outside of the matrix
that's funny that you say that because
you literally got now from every social
media he's in zion now he was banned
from youtube and tick-tock
so like you're definitely
you're definitely in the matrix my
friend in fact
in fact
you are
well you just got kicked out of the
matrix or whatever it is
you're in like that shitty
post-apocalyptic world eating gruel in
zion yeah in zion yeah
so we'll get to that
uh that's pretty exciting that's pretty
fun i also want to talk about there's so
many people man
what from what i've seen a hundred
percent men
who are like
i don't agree with andrew tate but
censorship is wrong
and i kind of want to address this
insane point that i keep seeing people
parroting
which i don't know if it's just like an
attempt at
it's like enlightened centrism that's
how i see it they're like
they can't possibly take a stance on
anything they're like [ __ ] jukeboxes
i mean it's a threat that's been around
on the internet forever that you know
no censorship no censorship free speech
100 of the time but the thing is nobody
actually agrees with that already
for example
if you ask these people should isis be
allowed to have a youtube channel
i don't think any of them would say
that's fine
right i think they would argue that isis
is doing things in real life that uh
should get them banned um and and and so
is andrew tate right
i agree with you that i don't think it's
logically consistent because everybody
believes that some censorship is
that's what i'm saying and it's really
just debating where the line is
exactly so then when they say no
censorship well they're not starting
from an honest point because where you
should start is like okay what do we
censor because i know you want to censor
sums up let's start with isis okay sure
let's start and then we go oh well what
about the clan what about the kkk should
they have a youtube channel they're not
doing anything illegal they're just
saying that
you know
uh
death to well
death to all jews that's not illegal to
say
right
so then you say well the clan
what about neo-nazis should they have a
youtube channel
death to all of them you know and if you
look at all those hate groups which is
what they are hate groups i don't think
anyone will give a [ __ ] if nazis or isis
or the kkk got their youtube channel
banned but somehow andrew tate who is a
hate group against women that's the only
difference right he hates women he
thinks women should be owned he thinks
women should be controlled he even said
stuff like they deserve to be r-worded
he he it's a hate it is a hate group
yeah the only difference is it's against
women and it's only [ __ ] men by the
way who are like oh if censorship isn't
the right way it's like dude
wow it's such a [ __ ] uh
can't see past the nose on your face
kind of thing because it's like
it's like telling me as a jewish dude
like hey don't be trying to get the
nazi's
page shut down bro it's free speech you
gotta just deal with it it's like it's
not even your [ __ ] you're not even on
the receiving end of the hate
right douche it's just so small-minded
it's so
sad because there's a lot of youtubers
who
i respect to it you know i respect and
that um
are good guys but they automatically are
like yo censorship is no i don't agree
with him but like i saw that so many
times on twitter i don't agree with
andrew tate but censorship is just not
the way
oh my god dude
and they always say couldn't disagree
more you gotta you gotta engage with
them and and defeat them in the battle
of ideas is sort of the attitude um
yeah yeah no that exactly no i'm sure if
we just had an open conversation with
andrew tate
he is um
he's going to change his mind and just
change everything precisely yeah andrew
tim dillon is coming on the show and i
will talk to him about that because he
is one of these people
what are these people
i'll talk to tim we can have an open
conversation about it
but
the world is better off without this
[ __ ]
in it okay exactly and just like groups
of thank you jordan and just like groups
of nazis we don't want them on youtube
either right
that's it
and by the way it's not set i don't know
many times we have to say this it's not
censorship it's youtube a [ __ ] free
speech has to do with government dumbass
free speech has nothing to do with
youtube and twitter and tick tock idiots
he can go [ __ ] make his own website
and say whatever the [ __ ] he wants there
and that's that
just like nazis and kkk
probably not isis this day and age but
maybe
not isis
yeah they don't get that
i mean
you know free speech is a is a uh ideal
that we claim to champion in this
country
um but there are there are other rights
too and one of them is like freedom of
association and
yeah that that really is just always the
end of the
argument to me when it comes to
censorship big tech blah blah blah
until until the government comes in and
uh
takes over social media platforms and
makes them a public utility
these are private companies
they have their terms of service they
can enforce them however they want like
they
they don't have to
allow this on their platform it's a
choice also they don't have to
participate and hate speech right like
if there's at that company they're like
i don't [ __ ] like this guy he's doing
hate speech
let's ban him they can [ __ ] ban him
they don't have to participate
you know
also we got a donation from someone she
said
my 17 and eight-year-old boys think he
has some good points that's what's scary
about it yeah that's [ __ ] terrifying
it's horrific and there's no marketplace
the whole idea of the marketplace of
ideas is so utterly stupid especially on
the internet people are just going to go
to a place that confirms their biases
they're not going to listen to somebody
like me say this all you you see tate
[ __ ] tater tots all the time in my
comments like they're not
no there's no longer nuanced discussion
against anything nobody [ __ ] listens
and also it's based on emotion right
like you hate women
you're not gonna you're not gonna
logically twist someone out of a [ __ ]
feeling they have you're not going to be
able to explain to nazis why you
shouldn't kill jews i mean they just
they hate jews they haven't they've
become emotionally
invested and hating jews it becomes so
part of their personality there's no
marketplace of ideas you know what i
mean
so i don't know i was frustrated all
weekend thank you prolapse penguin for
the gifted 10 gifted
thank you thank you to help for the
gifted that you didn't hope for the
gifted
yeah i don't know i was i was going
crazy kind of on the weekend seeing all
these people it's just so predictable
too you know it's like so predictable
so predictable
but actually what was a relief is that
there was a lot of people who were
enough people i would say that we're
being like no this is a good thing you
know i feel like that was the general
sentiment i saw a lot more
like that was a relief you know to see
because happy about it
i think people are afraid of being
labeled as like this guy's against free
speech and it's like people got to get
over that dumb [ __ ] it's not even an
honest argument
and we're
literally ruining society under this
weird concept of
social media platforms having to keep up
any account
it makes no sense
stop it
stop it
uh
monica said yep you can't say some of
what he says is right
with that kind of person or it's all or
nothing if you agree with him you have
to look in the mirror
keemstar is anti-ban yeah i know i've
got him in the dock don't worry about
that it's an idiot whatever side
keemstar takes you can guarantee it's
the worst and wrong side
talk about the allegations i'll get
there bobby you just chill
love that sound drop though well since
we're on i had some other stuff i want
to talk about but since we're on tape i
guess we might as well just finish it
yes so i actually wanted to talk about
dramaalert's take on this first and
foremost
so let's this is the new dramaalert
dramaalert kodak vs
nba young boy yeah he is home this is a
a great upcoming youtuber called got
diam
got damn zo
and he has a show called dramaalert
nation
it is so much going on yes sir
[Music]
banger intro too i'm afraid we get
claimed by him i don't know enough about
him yet
but um shout out to dramaalert huge fan
of the show drama love dramaalert yeah
huge fan let's get that
[Music]
the real drama alert yeah
[Laughter]
just a little gag for you [ __ ] uh
moving on so yeah i want to talk about
yes so his youtube channel was banned by
the way his youtube channel was tate
speech
a play on what
hate speech
which isn't allowed
epic to write in the name epic
uh he got banned
over the weekend on tick tock and
youtube basically what's left for him
uh yes twitch
yeah
there would be the last twitch is
awesome for that which
twitch
always
supporters of women over there at twitch
you know
a dude for showing his nipple uh or so
right like i don't even think dudes can
be shirtless on twitch is that right
love
ethan
you know what i'm not sure actually but
i know they can be shirtless if it's in
like a typical situation i mean kate was
on twitch shirtless talking to aiden
ross the whole time yeah that's true
what's the most obscene twitch rule that
people get banned for
well just like
women trying cleavage at all is like
what that's not true i mean
streams they ban people for that all the
time though they they changed the policy
arbitrary they made it a category now so
now if you're in that category you're
good oh right right if you're in the hot
tub category specifically it's okay but
honestly i think twitch at this moment
is like yo we can't be afforded banning
anyone we need every user we can get i
think so they must be in trouble don't
they ban for calling people simpson in
cells and stuff like that yeah you can't
say simp bro it's a cracker that's right
yo there's straight up like in cell
rights but yeah their rights matter
they're for gamer and in cell rights
primarily andrew fits in perfectly love
just said that's not true though is that
right love it's not true
well the simp and insult thing i think
is not super true ah i'm not sure
i'm not sure if that's true hi lina by
the way you're sitting in yes hello hey
b spot you're just there so how are you
how are you doing you're in this you're
you're there with love now yeah i'm
happy to be sitting with the cool kids
today i know yes thank you glad you that
you joined us
[Music]
i feel so quiet without zach it's just i
love that quietness
newly banned insults on twitch let's
[ __ ] go this was back in 2020 so
lives matter the uh the policy may have
changed since then but
yeah but anyway whatever if you let me
express my artistic uh ways i'm not
stopping you okay because then you know
i could go
you hey listen i'm you you're manning
this i've had it man all right
all right
all right yeah
bro you can't just be dropping walk a
flock of the whole doesn't make sense i
like it all right you do you
i love it yeah [ __ ]
what's what's he saying why does he
include that he goes yeah flaka i i
don't know
it's from eric andre's show yeah that's
that's hannibal uh
oh that's
they were [ __ ] with a guest and uh
maybe it's actually one of my favorite
eric entree interviews ever even maybe
just clip the first part of that play it
again uh i'm not sure how to but yeah
flocka yeah yeah
all right here i go it's
and she's like are you talking about
walk a flock of
maybe it's better with the yeah
maybe it's better to wind up to a pinch
to a pitch
jesus cameron you got two bunnies on you
today you know i'm trying to do a little
different ducky some crystals yep yep
what's that crystal do for you um i
don't know it just looks pretty okay
yeah
but i like that the
bunnies are keeping me warm right now so
that's nice
beautiful love that
so he's only left on on twitch uh
there's a couple of people who are like
trying to identify like what video
actually got him
banned
i mean there's so many
and then on the right there's like a
whole conspiracy theory you've seen this
where they're like he was talking about
like covet misinfo but it's like from a
long time ago where he's like
really we're still going on about the
covet thing they're like this is the
real reason he got banned it's like no
it's not that happened like a year ago
anyway here here's a great uh uh
andrew tate take
if you want to chop your dick off i have
nothing against that i'm not anti-gay
i'm not anti-transgender i'm not
anti-any of these things what i'm what i
am auntie is propagating your world view
on other people's children if you're gay
and you can't have kids why do you now
believe it's your right to go to other
people's kids and tell them how to think
if you've decided that the type of sex
literally how he makes you from
recreating from what
he's talking about like nobody has a
right to go tell somebody else's kids
how to live that's
literally his brain that's your whole
platform bro
100 of his business model well actually
not 100 the other half is sex
trafficking yeah yeah yeah webcam
dungeons but at least the hustler
university thing he's describing himself
yo that's true andrew what the hell
no but he see he's not gay so he has the
right to tell
yeah other people right he says if you
choose to be gay
and you know you can't have kids when
you're gay you made that choice then you
have no right to tell kids but if you're
straight
hustler university baby
so who is gay
uh
uh shout out for mysterio my husband and
i were lucky enough to meet a lot of you
on friday at zac's show
we had the best time
and we were taken aback by how nice and
genuine everyone was peace and love from
catherine john that's so nice yeah you
guys oh yeah how was that show it seemed
like it was a hit zach had a big show
at the cobra
viper
room
it was cool it was a lot of fun they
kept talking about this green room where
johnny depp would hang out and a lot of
other celebrities and we go into it it's
like a closet
uh so i was surprised by that but
besides that was really cool wait who
was talking about it zach or the uh it's
just well known about yeah it's well
known about the plays i've always heard
it
but river phoenix died there in that
green room oh okay interesting shout out
did you guys notice the one guy working
there that looked like a johnny depp
look-alike do you think that was
intentional or
did you guys notice him at all i did
notice that yeah and i was like that's
interesting he caught my eye on more
than one occasions about johnny depp
hanging around there
well congratulations zach glad you guys
all had a good time out there that's
great anyway back to andrew tape
somebody in the chat said andrew tate's
dad was cia
i just looked it up and like i have no
idea if there's any
validity to this but this is a fun
conspiracy theory
he's a he's an asset
man i never heard that drop i mean i
know krs1 i like krx one but i didn't
even know that was in there i just typed
in police and saw what came up yeah i
see
okay good whoop whoop oh that could be
good for friday
call the police and meet you
oh try and get gabe to do
i would love to
do his rendition of that
steve it's your right to go to other
people's kids and tell them how to think
if you've decided that the type of sex
you want to have will prevent you from
recreating from procreating that's your
decision right you've decided that
having sex with women isn't worth it for
you you don't want to have children
still talking about himself
yeah i don't think that's how
homosexuality works i don't think it's
about we decided it's like you choose
and then forfeit
you know you can adopt kids too there's
like other ways to have kids
i think he's [ __ ] stupid
or you could even have a foster or a
host mother or whatever
it's not like you forfeit your rights as
a human being because you're born gay
just like you know you don't forfeit
your rights as a human being when you're
born stupid which you know if
which is if that was the case we'd have
you locked up yeah he's stupid
[ __ ] got him yeah you got him dude
owned [ __ ] next position and you're
entitled to it that does not give you
the entitlement to go to other people's
families who did decide to have children
and raise them and try and program their
children leave the kids alone you could
be as transgender as you like don't come
talk to my kid about it that's my child
i will program my child with my world
views i raise them i pay for them
they're my kid they're not your idiot
this is the this is the
what a dude who's gonna end up in a home
uh
retirement home
withering away when his kids abandon him
anyway he's an idiot i mean obviously
he's just everything he says is horrific
homophobic
misogynistic violently misogynistic yeah
he wants to program his kid that's a
nice way to put it
girl please don't ever have kids like
i'm begging you
your dad shouldn't have kids clearly he
wasn't prepared
don't perpetuate the pain
you
well by his logic then if you get a
vasectomy then you also
[Applause]
can't tell people what to do with their
kids right i mean just like
yeah you made you made a decision you
can't have kids so vasectomy
you know get the [ __ ] out
and as soon as you have one you can't
tell your kids what to do anymore right
that's also true you're right as a
parent it's also true that's interesting
oh guys wait hold on let's get pride
minute going please
oh hold on
rainbow's up in the chat yeah i mean
hold on it started
okay guys
prime minute has started everybody you
know now is your time now is your minute
express yourself who you are your true
self don't be afraid of judgment
we love you uh
we support you
doesn't that make you gay
if you well
i mean if they're gay yeah i guess it
does make them gay
but pride minute it's not just about our
our
lgbtq plus uh
brothers and sisters
and
non-binary it's about the human
condition it's about supporting
everybody equally love and justice i
mean come on we're all humans
it's up to
the
cis heterosexuals
to put in the love and support for our
brothers and sisters
and non-binary that need it
and that's and now feel ashamed again
losers gay no more
losers
time to be feel ashamed again
cut it no more rainbows in chat stop
stop it
they're on a little bit of delay we'll
get back in the closet a little bit of a
leeway back in the closet
i'm more than gay pride minute is over
shame on you
you're all going to hell
yes so um
now that we got that out of the way
happy pride minute everybody um
let's see in a statement by the
washington po to the washington post
tick tock said andrew tate's account was
removed for breaking the rules on
content that attacks threatens and cites
violence against or otherwise
dehumanizes an individual group exactly
that's exactly bro that's the reason
that nazis kkk isis whatever they get
dropped andrew tastes no different man
it's a violent hate group
videos with the hashtag andrewtate have
been over viewed over 13 billion times
on tick tock man that is insane
tick tock told the independent that is
also working to remove clips of tate's
content posted on the app by other users
can i get an amen
w's today boys
they said even uh they said quote
tick-tock did misogyny is a hateful
ideology that has not tolerated on
tick-tock we've been removing
of a
a violative violative never heard that
word before
violative like violating
oh oh yes probably i just i never heard
it i've never heard that word in my life
violative
violating or tending to violate or
violate again maybe violative
videos and accounts
for weeks and we welcome the news that
other platforms are taking uh the action
against the individual
so there you have it love that the man
and then what's great by the way
is that just a month ago
um
he was
just bragging about how he can't be
canceled and it's just so juicy go ahead
ab
give me all those drops you got it's
actually me oh go ahead dan
cancel me i do not care i don't care
i exist outside of the matrix
no one can damage me
i don't even have a [ __ ] account
where you do ban me i don't even have an
account he's banning all of them
let's go
wait what character is that the turtle
from
lion king
oh jesus there is no turtle in the lion
king oh well i don't know what movie is
that
that's good
finding nemo kung fu panda oh
oh it's the kung fu panda gotcha
obviously the turtleneck
yes so he you know he says you can't be
canceled me
he says he doesn't care
i want all the people all the feminists
watching who want to go five million
views this was from
what's the date on this
doesn't show the date all of a sudden
am i crazy there's no date here
that's weird wasn't there always a date
here yeah
well it was july it was last month it
says one month ago so yeah oh cancel
people go cancel this guy because i can
tell he gives a [ __ ] don't try and
cancel me why
me i do not care i don't care i exist
outside of the matrix no one can damage
me doesn't matter you can i don't even
have a [ __ ] account will you ban me i
don't even have an account i do
what's interesting about this is that
also and i don't know how this happened
his hustler universary
university
affiliate and everything was also shut
down all the info didn't there that's so
crazy bro this man lost everything well
that theoretically was his own choice
and it it is already up with a uh
version 3.0 because apparently it was
already on version 2.0 i don't know if
we realized that um but we're oh this
was university 3.0 launched about an
hour ago so oh
right it might be yeah it might be
by the way we have a ton our last
episode
was i love baiting these morons bro how
does it feel to be a lemming like oh my
god somebody tells you on discord to go
leave a comment and you do it like
aren't you supposed to not be a sheep
isn't that the whole point of like
hustler university look you're lemming
you have no brain you've been turned
into a robot to do the bidding of one
dumb dude you want to you want to [ __ ]
him
you're trying to
he's never going to [ __ ] you okay
but anyway this was the last episode we
did i mean look at the quantity of this
top g everywhere it's not even like a
good comment you know what i mean top g
everywhere well yeah when you send your
minions out to [ __ ]
yes so what happens is they have this
discord with like a hundred thousand
people was the discord also shut down
i don't think so yes so and then they
have a room where they're like yo this
guy's talking [ __ ] on andrew tate
everybody goes spam
dude it's not just other users that do
that it's it's him or like or the people
running it with him
uh you know put out a ping
and say hey another here's another hater
go leave comments or whatever
which makes sense because we were and
when we first started talking about it
we were like so baffled by like we were
like where are all these comments coming
from but right yeah no he's got a he's
got a whole brigade squad ready to go
are you guys seeing this it's still
going
it's still
oh it looks
that's so embarrassing
for them
did i see me canyon's video yeah it was
great
we could i wonder if we can watch it i
mean me cam is not going to claim us
he's a homie let's watch it when we're
done with all this
um
so now let's get to the part
where
people who i consider
reasonable
are just like
sitting on the fence on this issue for
some reason
mudahar some ordinary gamer i like him i
think he's you know i squashed my beef
with him long time ago he's a he's a
he's a good guy i think
he says banning andrew tate is dumb
ideas should be challenged and if he
spreads misinformation misinformation
should be countered in the public sphere
yeah i mean
i just disagree with this fundamentally
on the internet
you literally i think we've learned over
the past
five ten years you cannot counter
misinformation
but also this isn't about misinformation
it's about a hate group right this isn't
a conspiracy or some crazy person just
in a corner minding their own business
this is a violent hate group
so it's i feel like it's kind of a
mislabeling of what it is he's doing
yeah i don't think he
got banned for um
just
saying
you know women should stay in the
kitchen or whatever no it's it's a lot
more than that okay [ __ ]
yeah also he runs a [ __ ] scam like he
runs up he's advertising a ponzi scheme
well that yeah like even that like just
on its own something it's worth some
some people will take him down
some i mean
in reality
i mean you wouldn't tell again i go back
to like isis would you say about isis
what we really need is to challenge them
in the public sphere i mean it sounds
idiotic when you say that against like
something that we all
except to be a hate group i'm sure you
could find some outliers that would
jerry but
mudahar is not out there gonna about to
defend isis
no i don't think so i mean rephrase that
banning the kkk is dumb ideas should be
challenged
misinformation i mean
saying saying
women deserve to be our word or does not
misinformation though it's just violent
hate right yeah
you know
he says if you actually believe bands do
something it only amplifies a shitty
message onto more users through
alternative programs that's been proven
to be absolutely not true
actually we've learned the opposite the
uh the platforming works oh yeah really
good 100 not true
shitty ideas should be countered with
sound reasoning in the public eye these
people should be mocked and not treated
as digital martyrs um
well you're the one turning him into a
martyr
right
it doesn't matter he can be a martyr
he's not he cried about it in his own
[ __ ] space why are you so cute when
you talk [ __ ] i mean
so you know i don't know i think the
problem with this argument is that he's
kind of
he's confusing misinformation with
violent hate group
also he tweeted last month about andrew
tate i just found out about him i refuse
to believe he's real he's trolling and
it's like okay if you thought that at
first you thought that at this point
people are deeming what he says as truth
and that's when it's dangerous so it's
not trolling it's not fun people are
listening to him and
you have
i just it makes me so [ __ ] annoyed
that like all of these men are like let
him do it let him do it and then what
the [ __ ] do you have to say to us yeah
oh exactly that's that's my favorite
part all these people are going to show
you are men i don't give a [ __ ] about
what you have to say about it i don't
want to hear about it right i'm sorry
i'm so mad
i'm glad to see i'm glad to see that
because it's like so far i don't see
it's like
the women's opinion on this is not
floating to the top
it's just dude being like this is
censorship
yep
um
let's [ __ ] let the women speak on
this issue
right
but again i think mood has a good guy
and also he made a
video like recently that that is a
really good expose on andrew so
i think a lot of these people like
moodle hard they just get caught up with
like
wanting to be on the right side of
something and i just think
it's just clear at this point that like
it's dangerous
yeah clearly it's dangerous with all of
the expose that he's getting like no
things are getting worse and he
shouldn't have more exposure
that is so true yeah
what what james said
rare james w um abba and preach these
guys are [ __ ] idiots andrew tate is
banned censorship will backfire no it
won't oh my god dude again more [ __ ]
men telling women
don't ban him the censorship will
backfire
let's watch it backfire he's gonna
disappear in the next month i guarantee
it
i mean how many people have been d
platform that just disa [ __ ] appeared
off the face of the earth now a lot
they're going to go follow them to cozy
tv
newsletter or whatever the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what was it though left can't meme how
many you guys he has like 400 views on
their native platform
now i didn't did anyone actually watch
this abbey and preach [ __ ]
i've been preached by the way i've never
really talked about them but they made a
video defending [ __ ] friction
fresh and fit yeah
yeah they did
they have a lot of bad takes
yeah it sucks i've watched a few of
their videos like earlier this year and
i thought they were hilarious me too but
then like yeah deeper dive it's like
[ __ ]
i actually had the same opinion and i
was really surprised when they're like
yo fresh and fit
there's no evidence to accuse them
picking coconuts from barbados but it's
just a woman's account so like
but whatever that doesn't matter but
here they're
they're doing the brave
act the defiant act of defending andrew
tate
such bravery
what is the psychological thing going
here because all these guys are like
i don't agree with him but
it's like
they're what they want to be they want
to present themselves as like the
enlightened free speech warrior yeah
yeah a lot of people you know have
strong opinions about free speech and
discord and what uh discourse and what
should be allowed and but i don't think
they care dan i think they
just care about their perception
because if you cared about free speech
you would understand
that has nothing to do with youtube in
the first place that's right as a
concept well they
free speech is a more broad
philosophical idea rather than
the type of free speech that's actually
enshrined by law well i'd like to know
what abb and preach think if the kkk had
a had a youtube channel one of them was
one of them was just on the stream with
um
the you know guidelines or whatever so
that i would say that they think that
that is fine
no that injury was so [ __ ] crazy
i would like to see oh you watch it yeah
it's easy to say it's fine you know what
i mean but it's a whole different thing
when the kkk has a mil they have a
[ __ ]
million subscribers they're getting a
shitload of views and people are joining
the kkk
everyone's thinking that this is a
really good idea this kkk thing
coffeezilla who
i don't think i've ever seen a bad take
from him
he's really good um
oh just to go back like this idea that
all censorship is bad it's not like
censorship
is not always bad
right some things need to be censored
and again we everyone agrees with that
okay
everybody does
it's just a matter of where you draw the
line
coffeezilla said i dislike tape but
but
kids are going to grow up thinking their
only weapon against stupid ideas is deep
platforming
you know
it's just doesn't happen that often to
do platforming
and i mean kids are growing up thinking
that
i think more kids are growing up
thinking that you can r-word a girl
because they deserve it because of
andrew tay
i don't i think this is a huge broad
generalization that sounds interesting
but i don't think it really is i mean
how many people actually get the
platform it's like i can count it on my
hand on my two hands you know what i
mean
and again this isn't misinfo this is a
violent hate group
are kids gonna think that our guys are
gonna think that about when isis's
youtube youtube channel got banned
d platforming it's just guys
i don't think they're understanding what
they're [ __ ] talking about
they don't see it as a violent hate
group because they're men
honestly they're men
and they don't they [ __ ] they they
can't stretch their imagination that far
yeah they just it's sad they're framing
it is like well i just i don't agree
with him right then
he is wrong and is not saying anything
of value or that should even be
entertained as like a valid opinion it's
not yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
that's the i think that's the next
disconnect these guys all
are not seeing this as a violent hate
group
uh that face when you're terrible at
arguing but you run a social media
company i mean
that face when men are being exist
outside of the matrix
that face oh that's a good that's an
interesting uh a down drop saw that saw
that image and remembered i have the
matrix one this is uh men when women are
being the victim of violent hate groups
this is what they have to say about it
why don't you just close your mouth
nothing that's what keemstar that's what
keemstar says how to protect yourself
uh willian that's no surprise i mean
censorship in 4k
andrew tate has been banned
i don't agree with him but
banning people because they say stuff
you don't like is just straight soft you
mean like the kkk would you be down do
you want the kkk or nazis or isis to
have youtube channels or do you think
that you just don't agree with isis
are you they're just saying stuff you
don't like i don't think you would
characterize it like that
it's just a difference of opinion
it's straight soft
say the man is a hate group okay you're
missing the [ __ ] point jake paul i
mean how could it take bad take come
from jake paul i don't get it
this is the most surprising
uh
both of these statements are true
i don't agree with a lot of tate's
opinions oh so he agrees with some
right that's nice
we have something
we have some overlap yeah
i don't agree with censorship
yeah so so let's rewrite this
i don't agree with a lot of isis's
opinions
but i don't agree with censorship who's
with me
you don't agree with any censorship what
about the n word people saying the n
word
that's that's censorship right i mean
essentially you say you can't say the n
word
that's censorship right
so you agree with censorship
again
you just don't know
it's just so [ __ ] dishonest bro such
losers these guys it just makes me sick
dude
i'm looking at all these people on
twitter and i'm scrolling through my
feed and seeing so many takes like this
and i'm like
these guys are such [ __ ]
idiots man
and you know what's funny is the men
complain they cry so fast and hard when
they feel like uh they're the victim of
something you know
men's rights and all this [ __ ] it's just
not fair
where would we be without men
doing impossible things those are
probably the things that jake's
referring to when he says
why he implies that he does agree with
him on
some things you know
[ __ ] you
i i certainly agree
when he says that women are inferior
how are we going to do without men
um
uh when whensership
thank you 50 gifted subs
from winsorship oh that's that's a
that's our prince is that the boy that's
star
welcome back soddy prince we love you
aaron asked 10 gifted thank you thank
you for the gifted air now thank you for
the gift dude
yeah i mean they're just missing the
point so hard
it's just so [ __ ] lena thank you
also um de-platforming him like is a
message on its own they're saying that
you should like counter it but that is
the message and it's saying that his
ideology is not tolerated what more do
they want that's the only thing you can
say to it yeah good point such a good
point such a good point abe you're out
lena's in
wiener weena that's a wiener
moment
um
yeah again it's just
that's a great okay ethan there's all
these there's all these freedom of
speech warriors uh out there um i wanna
i'm i'm declaring myself a freedom of
association warrior youtube
youtube
pays for the data centers they created
this platform
they are free to have whoever they want
on it they are not obligated to give you
a megaphone to
millions of people they're not they're
just not obligated to do that and you
can disagree with their choice but
that's their
choice and that
again until
until it gets uh nationalized we
nationalize youtube and it becomes just
a public utility then you know the
government will have to adhere to the
constitution but until then we're
talking about a private company you can
do whatever the [ __ ] they want whatever
you want then that is
you know lena you make such a good point
it's like the censorship is the message
that's the whole [ __ ] point you
idiots i think you've said that so well
uh go ahead though
i think a lot of people confuse like the
company's opinions and the thoughts with
the shareholders thoughts because the
company at the end of the day is just
mirroring whatever the shareholders and
the general public
wants yeah so if the general publics
don't like this dude think it's hurtful
they're going to do it for the better of
the company and for the stock price
exactly they don't have opinions they
don't have thoughts they don't have
anything they're trying to push it's
just the stockholders young people think
about the three that's a whole nother
angle right that justifies what they're
doing too it's like they don't even
they're not even here to make a moral
judgment they're just trying to protect
their business 100
and yeah i mean and yeah that's another
that's another layer to it and you can
have a debate about whether that's a
good thing or not
i i personally am of the opinion that
some of these social media companies
because they've become so important
should be nationalized or or at least
much more heavily regulated than they
are but
we don't live in that society so if
you're just looking at
realistically
his capitalism baby they yeah
they don't want to associate they don't
want to associate with this guy they
don't want youtube to be a place that
you can go to to
hear him and that's their choice that's
their frankly that's their freedom of
speech what do we do about it also the
employees i mean look they don't again
there's people in that company
there's a billion reasons why they would
do this there's a gillion reasons why
this is a good or maybe there's actually
just three i hate when people say that
there's a million it's like well we
identified three
uh but thank you for the gifted thank
you marina thank you for gifted
uh but um
there's so many different reasons why
this is okay right
somebody said what arc of one piece are
you on dude i'm glad you asked
reckless flamenco i i don't want to get
a huge tangent but i'm on the water
seven and it's so good it's like
probably the show got really good now
i'm deep into the water seven story arc
strip weirdos
one piece of rules
anyway continuing on
faze ronaldo i don't know who this guy
is but he's facing the [ __ ] up
you cannot agree with andrew tate but
isn't banning him off like stu bro are
you seriously the are you did you
actually my brain like my eyes crossed
when i was reading
isn't banning him on like stuff bro did
you
can we just bro can you just erase this
bro are you [ __ ] high right now
what's great though is he is saying the
same thing as coffeezilla and mudahar
and it this is this is honestly a more
honest way to say it because it just
shows how like
not very deep it's not that deep but
isn't banning him on like stuff just
saying he can't have freedom of speech
lol
exact same [ __ ] stupid exact same
intent
a little less eloquent
you know
i'm so glad he got banned you know what
i mean
also i don't care about his freedom of
speech or uh uh
when he's talking about
he's a hate he's a hate group and trying
to take freedom away from so many
exactly
like
what are you what is he standing on what
are all of you standing on again he he's
not going to prison well not for this
anyway probably for other things
he's free to say whatever the [ __ ] you
want and by the way this guy doesn't
even live in america why are you all so
concerned about this man's freedom of
speech he lives in romania he lived
there because it has lacks rape laws
what [ __ ] entitlement to free speech
does this guy who lives in romania who
bribes the mafia there
you know what i mean it's like all what
are you talking about benefits every
it benefits everybody okay that's fair
point joe
hurts nobody
see that is where we disagree
uh
supposedly the constitution of romania
does guarantee freedom of speech oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay shout out
andrew
what's up okay shout out andrew chet
free speech for everybody yeah but he's
not being arrested he's not being
squelched by the government it has
nothing to do with free speech freedom
of speech and i just don't understand
yeah again like freedom a violation of
freedom of speech would be like i'm
throwing you in jail for saying this the
government is putting you in jail
for saying something they don't like yes
that's what it guarantees
like in china they don't have free
speech
if you say the wrong thing you go to
[ __ ] jail
correct
[ __ ] your mom like you can't even talk
to you you can't even talk to your
friends about [ __ ] not i'm not talking
about the internet i'm not right i'm not
talking about the right to broadcast it
to millions of people on youtube i'm
saying me and dan are having a
conversation about the government i say
the wrong thing i go to jail that's
freedom of speech idiots
[ __ ] dumbass but isn't banning him on
like stuff
bro you're not old enough clearly to be
using twitter
go back to school
man phase blanks
so he didn't actually tweet about it i
went to go see if he had a take and he
he hasn't tweeted in a while but then
i got curious and i went to his likes
tab and sure enough is so this is just
repeats of some of the other ones oh
this is awesome he's so pissed about
this another [ __ ] dude
also like
oh god it's just so predictable it's so
sad so he liked mudahar's he likes
sneakers friend of speech is dead and
bots are happy about it
freedom speech is dead who went to jail
it's like i don't know
yeah he like coffee zilla so he like so
he's in he's not banned off all
platforms he can stream to
again coz he's going to corner and goes
and say whatever the [ __ ] he wants yeah
you can go to times square and do it
there keemstar things aren't that
[ __ ] deep
i try to skip the keemstar part but i
don't know how to use this program
that's right that's fair you're doing
good you're doing it you're doing great
sweetie
things aren't that [ __ ] deep how does
it feel back there are you getting a
hand for it or i'm having i'm getting a
hang of it i'm having a blast okay i
feel powerful
yeah good good good w-a-b
wow
talk about the allegations thank you
let me speak okay
that's zack watching right now
[Laughter]
um so those are all the enlightened
centrists
keem of course
you know keem has he's got a good take
on it team has got a [ __ ] ultimate
take didn't have he didn't have other
text tweets it's just this video he did
the thing is uh that album i was trying
to keep it to the enlightened centrist
keem isn't a centrist he's just outright
he's just a misogynist he's just a tape
fan yeah roll it
well i want to see what else he said oh
god
oh my god i [ __ ] up
he retweeted his own tweet from three
hours ago
wow
classic he's talking about it a lot
actually
oh guys this is great a
limited run of happy punch
athletic clothing guys
this is huge y'all
people are really gonna watch this logo
bro he ripped that logo off for sure
oh actually speaking of which
um
oh is that what's up
should i show that or no
okay
okay [ __ ]
it's something about i just want to say
because people be like oh what are they
talking about he made some tweet about
trisha that i don't want to show that's
all because i don't want to get involved
in
drama yep
ride my dick yes so here's his video
this is a this is a fresh hot off the
press it's just from three hours ago
world
the online world
is a metaverse it's in a alternative
reality
i want you to imagine in the real world
there is an evil dictator and this evil
dictator is doing horrible he's named
ethan klein
tater and this evil dictator is doing
horrible things in his country and he is
getting criticism from opposing
politicians and the journalists within
the country how the evil dictator
responds and we've seen this all
throughout history is by arresting those
opposing politicians and those
journalists and killing them
so has anyone been arrested or killed
big l on my part no
once that happens then we can start
worrying
but i don't think that's anything anyone
he's dude you're such an idiot bro
go ahead go on
silencing them
so they can no longer oppose the evil
dictator's views
famous comedian dave chappelle once said
that twitter is not a real place what he
was referring to is that the online what
kind of quote is that
it's from the great philosophy it
literally does nothing to add to his as
the great chappelle once said twitter is
a place where you go and tweet
and it was used in a book
it's an
it's a metaverse it's an alternative
reality we don't even communicate online
i don't think that's what chappelle
meant by that quote he said the opposite
he says it's not a real place
he goes no what he meant is it's a
metaverse it's an old
alternative reality an alternative
reality we don't even communicate online
like we would in the real world
and online why is he trying to be like
vsauce right now
you get that vibe
can we pull the vsauce uh yeah he does
have the cadence theme song you're right
this is
you got a keemstar here you got to pull
this
vsauce theme vsauce instrumental
vsauce here this is vsauce if he was
like a misogynistic white nationalist
freak
i don't know if keemstar is a white
nationalist let's be honest
yeah here it is check this out guys
vsauce an alternate dimension
what he was referring to is that the
online world isn't
it's a metaverse it's an alternative
reality we don't even communicate online
like we would in the real world
and online there are dictators those
that are in power those that are in
control and when they get criticism when
their worldview is being opposed they
also
arrest and kill
those people
[Music]
was a fire alarm was that his video
yeah oh what the [ __ ] bro change your
batteries
those are people who live with that
people live with that sound yeah
literally love is right and it drives me
i think
yeah i've been with friends or at
friends apartments
and i say like what the [ __ ] is that
sound and they're like what are you
talking about and i i think they're like
gaslighting me but they actually have
like
grown to block it out it's insane
yeah i would not be able to ignore that
maybe it's not actually a low battery
maybe it's actually about to go off
because this smoking hot take is just
filling up the room with carbon monoxide
right now dude you're literally in a bar
full of like fuel like you should fix
your fire detector dude
they do it yeah i mean do i even need to
explain why this is so dumb it's like
it's a non-starter
first of all you're trying to compare
twitter to
a
country which is not so there's no
there's no governing body there and
second of all you're comparing people
getting banned for hate speech
to
people being murdered in silence which
again it's like
the leap of la of
logic there makes no sense
coming with that heat and and and
furthermore
furthermore
you look like [ __ ] jafar so
[Laughter]
i'm sure that's been pointed out before
you've said that before yeah
you know you're in trouble which isn't a
bad thing by the way i mean some people
like jafar he's a handsome he's he is
handsome jafar and powerful too now he's
comparing me to him
yeah but um
uh
it's just i don't know
do i need to say anything else about it
about his take well also
again
they're not criticizing they're not
getting banned for criticizing twitter
right that's what he's making it sound
like like they're suppressing
criticizing the establishment literally
the guy is just a hate uh he's just
doing hate speech
they're you know what i mean it's not a
scandal if they were like
i hate twitter for this reason and get
banned for that then maybe you'd have a
point
but you have no points
just like your iq single digit zero
digit
dumb vegetative state
you dumb mother [ __ ]
um
oh and then andrew tate went on aiden's
stream of course
sam i loved your memes i want to show
your memes that you posted i thought it
was so good
before i show this sam crushed the meme
game
uh can you someone pull that up for me
yeah i'm grabbing it right now my
favorite was your comparison on aiden
ross i was like oh that's so true dude
we watched beauty and the beast last
night i've never seen it before
and i was like there's a lot of real
life comparisons i could make from this
right now
you have never what the [ __ ] is your
twitter i have never seen what's your
twitter sam little little texas toast
no
no texas how'd you get that no it's not
that it's um
just sam temple with the one
same type of one i got damn temple
thank you
he walked so tape could run gaston which
is great
but here's where it gets in my opinion
great even better and the role of a
lifetime aiden ross oh that was so true
he totally is that little [ __ ] boy
isn't he he totally is and that's what
he's doing here it's so good i
understand that with great power
in the role of a lifetime adam ross is
the ultimate ass kisser great influence
comes great responsibility oh he this he
just starts crying bro get those i'm not
part of the matrix sound bites ready a b
have your finger on the button for those
or dan whoever yeah
you're doing great abe you are i'm
having fun thank you thank you yeah yeah
he's helped me with the team feel
confident you're doing it i got it yeah
you forget about it forget about it huh
hey zach don't come back
yeah we don't need you no more
just kidding love you zach
and i'm very understanding of the
situation i i think that uh
i'm a strongly religious man
i believe that god will prevail the
truth will prevail right if you want to
defend me then stick up for me in a
respectful way even if they're insulting
oh my god bro
the tone has changed all of a sudden
he's a he's a pious man
he's turning to god i never heard him
mention god be respectful when you're
defending me what what where's the king
liar dude
you gotta keep playing those tate sound
bites okay
from before the band
[Music]
do it in a respectful way because just
arguing back and forth in a bitter
immature hate and hate way isn't going
to work show that if you're a fan of
andrew tate you're a respectful person
and i was trying to
damage me
say that again cancel me i do not care i
don't care yeah yeah what theirs now
what weird fans of andrew are respectful
just like him yeah i learned it from you
dad yeah
wow
all these millions of young men
and now who knows where they're gonna go
right and you're right it's it's kind of
crazy
think of the kids man
they got nowhere to turn wow hey man
[ __ ]
where are they gonna go
a direct quo uh you want arguments you
want war what's the context of that the
discord the andrew tate discord when
they were given instructions for
hustlers university
um they were instructed
to post controversial content about him
to get super high views and explicitly
said you want arguments you want war
and now it's deleted be respectful guys
yeah uh let's show everybody the
takeaways
the most beautiful people yes
no one can damage me
this is so satisfying you know i knew
this guy was going to eat [ __ ] but i
didn't expect to be like this fast and
it's just so satisfying and he's so
deserved
and also
not whatever i don't go in too hard on
on
other people
i'm a changed man
literally pure degeneracy or hatred
because that's what gets the most views
and it's a shame
it does it does now i want to ask you a
question wait he's saying he doesn't
wait what because referring to people
like us as being
a black hole of now word the bat now
we're the bad guys
we're the hateful people no
feminists it's people like him that are
keeping women back are you talking about
you
oh
damn
keeping women back
what
what's this who is this guy
this is andrew uh we need
an alter ego what is it andrew
uh
andrew uh look late
andrew
andrew saint there you go
it's the pious version andrew saint
that's good
all of a sudden he gets banned
i love god
jesus hello my followers be respectful
we where where the children go
i'm healed maybe you've got to play
jesus you got to play the
the reverent church music that's what
zach would do right now
uh
i'll look for it let's see try like god
or church if you're looking for a
keyword probably one of those
oh wait this might be it yeah flocka oh
it's not one second
god damn it with the flocka bro
he has two programs one of them i get
the other one i'm still learning the
other one has more of the music so
oh man yeah okay well we get we get you
guys understand the joke that i was
building in my mind there so that's all
that matters yeah
it does now i want to ask you a question
let me move on to the next thing
andrew i've been seeing reddit posts
twitter posts about you
in the role of a lifetime
andrew tate
once a womanizing
hateful misogynist
turned
pious
man of god join us in the role of a
lifetime
as andrew tape
ascends the ranks of the church to
become
the pope
yes
pope
tate the pope
join us as andrew tate takes over the
catholic okay oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i
know i know i'm buzzkill but it says no
copyright music but sometimes on youtube
they do that and it's not really
copyright music wait what the [ __ ] that
wasn't from the database it's from
zach's database okay yeah yeah but
i've never heard zach play this so i
don't know if he pulled it and tried it
[ __ ] okay all right well it's important
what's important is we blame zach for
this no well yeah maybe you're right
yeah you should ask zach i don't know if
he's watching you could text him i'm
assuming if it's in the database it's
got to be royalty free
people are saying the music is super
loud by the way
sorry too loud people are spamming too
loud baby got it you're leaving the
levels to a b i mean no offense i mean i
love ab he's doing a great job with the
sound bites but the levels had to piece
so bad i couldn't hold it oh dan ran to
the bathroom
anyway
and about teachers basically saying like
andrew tay you know i'm i'm a ninth
grade teacher and my my my male students
are basically telling girls to get in
the kitchen and you know what i mean it
doesn't matter what you do in school
tomorrow what are you doing school you
need to get in the kitchen and you need
to you'll never amount to what a man can
do okay aidan ross
let's see if he let's see
maybe he's just teeing him up with the
softball
and they're blaming you for that and i
just want to know what is your what are
your thoughts on seeing posts like that
and like what is that what are you yeah
this is softball
you know like what do you have to say
about that
i know that's not the case i mean a lot
of the things that have been taken up
and chopped up and thrown online are
things from a very long time ago when i
didn't have a fraction of the influence
i have now i'm not apologize i'm not
apologizing for them i'm not even saying
that you know that they're intrinsically
wrong i'm saying that when you produce
as much content as i have like six years
of posting and for the longest when you
create content for six years you're
obviously just going to come out with
violent misogyny one day and by the way
i don't disavow any of it yeah and by
the way he throws that in there too so
it's like it's gonna be clear great
point
just to be clear
i love that i stand by every word of it
you go you go where did you guys learn
this andrew tate
like all of them he's like it's not true
spirit of time
what happened you asked for this three
or six years of posting find three
minutes and cut it up and chop it up and
throw it on tick tock bro there is like
a [ __ ] life a roll of a lifetime
supply if you say horrible [ __ ]
[Laughter]
there's there's only three minutes of
content
and that's what he asked for people to
do too
in the hustlers university that's
literally the point that's like what
you're taught is to share to chop up
those clips and post it everywhere what
you what you said olivia really kind of
just says it all doesn't it yeah the
discord literally i can't remember
exactly the percentages but it was like
you want 47
fans and
what's the 53
uh haters wow
it's like huh
okay what do you mean now
on repeat and make that person look bad
anyone can do that right i agree with
that you could definitely take a look at
that
yeah yeah yeah yeah man we gotta get a
soundbite of gaston's little [ __ ] boy
every time adam
there's gotta be you're right gaston
yeah that's not fair at all gaston
you know his name's lefou level even
more of an l
[Laughter]
yeah so that could happen to anybody
could happen to anybody you could take
away you take my beliefs and chop them
up which by the way i stand by all of
those beliefs i was 100 right in all of
them but you put it out there and it
makes me look bad and any you know this
could happen to anyone wait guys the
role of a lifetime
andrew tate as the pope you missed a lot
when he went to the bathroom dan
i am the pope
of a lifetime he's a pious
if a hate mob gets behind it and tries
to purport that that's your only world
view if if people don't think critically
and they don't sit there and look and
analyze for themselves i actually have
never heard them say anything but like
violently misogynistic and homophobic
[ __ ] like that's literally all he talks
about and sit there and go okay well
clearly a lot of this cannot be true
because this man is a free man he has no
criminal charges he's never gone to jail
no dude you're not going to say that
about yourself when you're being
investigated for human trafficking
novels around the world freely in and
out of you know western countries this
man i'm willing to bet cannot enter the
united states at this moment
there's no [ __ ] shot
if he comes to an airport in america he
will be arrested at the gate that's my
that's my my opinion
do you have your passports did you get
your shots
girl would you like to come with andrew
tape to romania yo wasn't there a
podcaster who said
he tried to get him out
to america and he said he couldn't come
i remember hearing something about that
whatever he has nothing against him
obviously these things aren't true but
some people don't think beyond the
headline they see the headline and they
believe the headline instantly right
what's actually what's actually right
gaston you're so right
people just read the headline they don't
know your true heart gaston like i do
you're a dick rider you're a dick sucker
hop off my [ __ ] dick
well said
bit inconvenient about the instagram
band the only thing that's inconvenient
is i'm going to send you a picture aidan
is that i launched an initiative
to donate money
to a charity aimed at protecting women
against domestic violence have you seen
this
yes so this is some weird funny thing
he's trying
breaking news
what
he's been banned off of twitch as well
oh he had a twitch channel
[Music]
it might be coming but whatever he can
be on twitch people get bored of him
there it's like
he's a one-trick pony i mean it's just
not that entertaining for much longer if
all he's on twitch
too bad though
okay gaston keep talking i i like when
to hear you talk
look let me send it you put the picture
up i've just sent it to you so what was
happening is i understood that some
people who only viewed the headlines and
didn't listen to me because i've made
i've made countless videos talking
is that what they're say oh is this the
person who ripped it no that's it no
that's aidan
i was like whoa what's happening about
how women need to be protected how women
need to be respected how important
the screen what the [ __ ] is he doing
well he famously leaked uh his money
from steak by doing that by accidentally
an idiot doing screen capture instead of
window capture jeez oops how much oh
here's here's the post apparently that
he posted right before his band i've
decided to show what a loving nice man i
am
i am don't i'm going to donate a
significant fund
to charities which support women against
domestic violence however i will also
donate significant funds to charities
which help men with mental health issues
[ __ ] i hope i support men and stick up
for them
and the haters and liars think this
means i hate women no we can both win
people need support we can support men
and women top g has kindness for all and
i got news for you
wait
so so donate it who's stopping you
well now he doesn't get publicity for it
so what's the point let's see what he
says about it i respect my mother i've
done loads of things positive about
women but people who don't want to look
into it and actually understand the real
me they would only view the headline and
assume i was about let's put this post
on the screen so people can read it
gaston he's just so down in the dumps it
just makes me feel so bad
pains me to see gaston in pain like this
look what a good guy he is
i guess now he's just having a big joke
out of it that person right so i decided
okay well let's counter that narrative
because with great power comes great
responsibility so i put this post up i
don't know if you can put it on the
screen it's on there it's on the stream
i already did a guest song i'm one step
ahead of you don't worry buddy i could
read your mind
i am a song i would have to live up in
the beginning
and i said that look a lot of people are
confused because i'm trying to build men
up and help men understand that they
have a value too because i think in the
world today not many men feel valuable i
think a lot of men are very very sad and
depressed i'm trying to encourage the
men to feel powerful and feel valuable
they think i'm trying to drag women down
and that's not the case and i said i
think i think and i'm speaking on the
people that are trying to bring you down
but i think the issue is what people on
the other side are saying is that it's
coming off as misogynistic because
why
it's coming off that way what is this
does this man not know how to stream i
mean this is his job
he's opening notepads
the streaming interface
hayden [ __ ] get your [ __ ] together
man
get a second monitor or something what
the [ __ ]
i mean this is basic [ __ ] right love
yes
but i wasn't sure if that was him though
because he had both hands in there well
when that happened yeah that was if it's
someone who's serious looking i agree
yeah but but so well where'd the notepad
come from i don't know what people on
the other side are saying is that
it's coming off as misogynistic because
why
recording him i think the first time
whenever he showed the screen because it
lined up with him showing the photo was
him and the second time it could have
been the guy recording
probably
we got layers
i like to think it was him
let's just go with that
yeah
coming off that way i'm not saying you
are massage i'm saying it's coming off
that way i'm not saying you're
misogynistic gaston you love women
you can't push back even a little bit
i'm not saying you're misogynistic yeah
it's awesome no
i know you're not misogynistic
when i pretend i'm your girl you treat
me great
it's interesting i'll tell you why and
the reason is is because they're very
very careful and they're very very
selective right so the reason i was
talking about that charity post is
because i put a post up saying i'm going
to donate i'm going to donate a dollar
for every like get into a charity which
supports women against domestic violence
and also a charity that helps men with
mental health issues because there's no
point in trying to support one against
the other we're all people of course and
i pledged i pledged 1.2 million american
dollars hello
go
send it donate it prove your point
like
who cares that it was erased bruh
toxic masculinity where would we be
without andrew tate
he's teach he's helping young men
i'd love to actually get jordan
peterson's opinion on andrew tate i did
not [ __ ] my dog
that didn't get single that didn't get a
single publication they ignored it
completely and at the same time they're
saying i hate women when i'm the one
who's giving away six hundred thousand
dollars and that that that post was live
and i was gonna put the receipt up
tomorrow morning
so
yeah it's very very selective what
they're doing and that's what's scary
because i think a lot of the things that
are out there that make me me look like
i'm talking about women in a bad way
what's your uh what's your course called
hustlers university would you ever do
like a section dedicated to just
strictly women or like you know like
kind of like teaching oh yeah there's a
huge demand for that
women can't wait to learn from andrew
[ __ ] tate on how to live their life
um you know because like that's how i
look at it right without women we have
no life you know we all love our mothers
we all you know yeah so
we you know a lot of people that are
starting to think that
you know like i said you're a misogynist
you're putting a woman down and stuff
your mom would you ever
think about considering about doing
anything specifically dedicated to just
women
completely i mean the hostage university
is open forever is such a dumb idea
literally lying who is going to end what
woman is paying him
also no he's not
yeah he won't
definitely not well he know well he's
just trying to make money i mean he
knows that's a dumb idea
yeah that wasn't anybody rhetoric about
women at all
even if he decides he wants to make
money off of them
dumb nobody would pay for that period
and join and they can participate some
of our best students are females inside
of there
so it's not even gendered in that regard
i gave charity to both men and women's
cherry because i believe in people as
opposed to one gender above the other
but the people who dislike me are very
very desperate to grasp aiden
you [ __ ] suck at your job bro
i don't even know why you're popular
so bad
but i'm a hater s [ __ ] so it's fine
maybe maybe there's other things that
going on damn i don't give a [ __ ]
there's no oh there's not okay yeah he
sucks
um
nitsy
aiden ross finally oh this was actually
interesting
aiden ross
i had a little [ __ ] moment here about
andrew
this was quite interesting i'm not doing
it you're just like look at you bro like
there's nothing i'd say like you're just
so like
you're you're like you're you're fine
like you're every girl's like fantasy
bro like there's something i can say
i
bro if i was a girl
you might be like
and i got nudes for you you literally i
don't know
like you do anything you want to me okay
i do i come here i do hear a lot of
calls oh my god andrew doesn't even know
how to deal with it i had to go
this way i'm the closest thing to god
she's ever seen i've had that all right
that's dick sock to be honest
but i'll
said that's too far only because he's
not the one saying no [ __ ] bro
but he's just doing his sus routine
right i mean
yeah yeah he does do that i suppose so
that was pretty funny though i liked it
andrew took it seriously yeah women do
tell me i'm close to god so thanks bro
yeah
hear that all the time
oh jesus
there you have it
oh there's more tate news hustler
university has shut its affiliate
marketing program
he's trying to relaunch hustler's
university 2.0
3.
excuse me
let's take a look at hustler university
experience of the future of learning
that's a huge scope
just learning straight ups learning into
revolution
massive upgrade spots available
uh apply now
i have to apply interesting
50 a month
damn
fifty dollars a month
that's crazy
do you think that all of the students
students from hustlers university 2.0
their purchase is going to be honored to
3.0 or do they have to buy a new
i have to buy the upgrade i would say
yes because they don't want to turn off
their
reoccurring good points
wait no olivia didn't you see that part
of the problem was they got dropped by a
pavement
well they didn't stripe didn't
explicitly say that they dropped them
but in the discord
um it says
stripe is not commented specifically
they denounce
get rich quick schemes and then a
community leader in the discord said
a decision had been taken to close
affiliate marketing schemes saying
although it was very successful it had a
few issues and stripe wasn't working
anymore right
so interesting
so let's see uh
yeah i mean that was his main source of
revenue was through the
affiliates program
and uh it sounds like stripe
canceled their processing that's so epic
so they have to re-enlist and spend 50
more dollars to
get the same i guess you're right i
guess i guess they don't have any
reoccurring payments anymore well what a
[ __ ] nightmare yo that's crazy that
like in two days they overhauled the
whole website isn't it yeah and like
nobody could get money anymore so that's
why like
they had to scramble and let everybody
know what was happening
tate made a statement to the observer
saying it was a massive shame he had
been removed by instagram and urged it
to reinstate him
i thought he didn't care about being
canceled he said internet cessation
cancel me i do not care i don't care
yeah that's at odds with this statement
he said internet sensationalism had
purported the idea that i'm anti-women
when nothing could be further from the
truth
adding that he has donated to charities
benefiting women
it's very unfortunate that old videos of
me where i was playing a comedic
character what he's playing a character
come on
they've been taken out of context and
amplified to the point where people
believe absolutely false narratives
about me amplified by him again and his
[ __ ] minions
at his request he goes i am
genuinely innocent
i truly believe god will prevail for oh
you are [ __ ]
yes so anyway here is the two guy i mean
here is aiden ross guys
i wouldn't be mad if this somehow got in
front of him because i think this is
perfect
boy i hate to see you sound like this
[Laughter]
gee williker's gaston
i'd do anything to cheer you up
all right let's thank our sponsors real
fast how long we've been going today
very long
uh hour 45.
are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah
no i mean
no we've been going to hour 45 picking
coconuts from barbados
all right let's do it um babel
thank you to babel
for all of your summer travels whether
you're going abroad or staying domestic
just with some music
oh yeah yeah geez quiet anyway
uh please please hold
exciting music all right sure yeah all
right this is an exciting opportunity
all right here we go
all right what yeah it's perfect i don't
know if i can talk with this level of
and
okay dramatic music
hmm creepy chill me something more kind
of backgroundy okay
oh [ __ ]
okay i love this the ricegum freestyle
yeah classic for all your summer travels
whether you're going abroad or staying
domestic or want to immerse yourself in
the culture now's the perfect time to
start with babel
babel's a language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscriptions
thanks to babel's addictively fun and
easy bite-sized language lessons
there's still time to learn a new
language before you reach your
destination dude babel freaking rules
man
they have 10-minute lessons
that you can start having a real-life
conversation a new language as little as
three weeks
other language learning apps use ai for
the lesson plans but babel's lesson were
created by over 150 language experts
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german
and more
plus babble speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
punctuation and accent
hey
there are so many ways to learn with
babble
in addition lessons you can access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes
plus
it comes with the 20 day money back
guarantee
20 days
start your new language learning journey
today with babel we i actually taken
babel
um i was messing around with it
and i was doing spanish classes
so fun actually it's really fun i was
having a good time and it's really easy
to learn
they have like uh these really cool
interactive classes it's great it really
is so good i mean ian is practically
fluent in french what are you afraid of
ian
we
we
anything else you want to add in french
no
what
just no
no did you say no in france with a
little stank on no
no
no
excellent pronunciation nope
hey ian what'd you have for breakfast in
spa in french
it does
it
guys right now save up to six
oh oh and oh how do you do it
right now you can save 60 percent off
your subscription when you go to
babel.com h3tv that's babel.com
h3tv
for up to 60 off your subscription at
babel it's a language for life
thank you to our wonderful sponsor we
love you and finally you know you love
them it's honey
okay little roster vibe
slow like honey brother
all right
not mad
we take the daisy
honey boy that might not get the context
of the chet hanks thing yeah there you
go switch it up
thank you baby what is this
it's the right song how is this the
right song it's like a rave because i
see three songs and i played two of them
already this bass line is too hot like
it's too heavy i can't do that
are you saying it's not loud enough
no it's just
don't worry about it
[Music]
honey
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer
oh
i love honey man i feel like a rock star
there you save money on honey every time
man i'm at that checkout
it pops up automatically you don't have
to think about it you don't have to
think about it dude comes down it's god
i love honey
i think we all use honey at this point i
mean you're straight up missing out on
free money these are all savings that
we've got
it's a plug-in takes two steps to
install
and it basically scours the internet
automatically for you at checkout and
applies the best coupon it fines
manually searching for coupons is a
thing of the past
it's free to download
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites and when you check out
the honey button appears and all you
have to do is click apply coupon wait a
few seconds as honey searches
and fines for that site and if honey
finds a working coupon you watch the
price drop magically and these are all
real
savings from me and elo
let's go let's go yeah i mean we've
saved money this is postmates which was
that was a crazy one
you don't furniture
uh
lots of furniture places actually do
this stuff kind of stuff tech you know
i've saved every g fuel even damn
so i mean i've probably saved a thousand
dollars plus with with honey
um
yes so it doesn't just work on the
desktop now either works on your iphone
too just activate it on safari on your
phone and save it on the go if you don't
already have my honey you are missing
out on savings and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show
i use honey i love honey i think
everybody here uses honey
and dude this music is just so skits
overall i'm having a hard time i don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on you gotta
chill just cut the music all right all
right all right all right
i didn't even finish oh that's dan
messing with me dad i let me finish the
ad read you get so anal about it
and you're putting all right
before i go no no no no that's ap he's
trying to throw me under the bus dude
you gotta chill bro i don't have any
music back here gotta chill back there
get honey for free
at joinhoney.com h3tv
jesus man is this isn't off the rails
this is h3tv we'll save it for wednesday
thank you to honey and uh babble we love
them guys please
support them
thank you
yeah
i still i still don't know if there was
me or dan
i didn't play the music okay then it
wasn't me i apologize dan i don't have
any music okay i think you were hitting
buttons i'm sorry
all right so we've got
man i can't believe we talked about that
for so long
well i have to pee so
oh no
uh let me see what else we got i mean we
have a lot
kanye west selling clothes in a trash
bag
that's pretty fun maybe we can finally
get to the trailer thing today
no let's put it off
let's do this
and a bunch of other fun stuff at the
top of the dock all right i'm just gonna
go pee i'll be right back maybe i'm
gonna pee in my trash can down here i
don't know
hit me with that hit me with that
symphony in it maybe i don't even know
where it came from i don't know
let's enjoy i enjoy the sweet sound yeah
let's see
what is that the
the william tell literature is it
william tell me maybe not i think it's
like
it's like the 1800s oh you're right yeah
symphony yeah it's tchaikovsky's uh yes
there you go yeah oh yeah this is it
this is it
this is chinese yeah this is 1812
overture i'm sorry yeah
there's that russian ballet he was ahead
of the curve listen to this [ __ ]
the w
tchaikovsky that's a real departure
waikovsky the nutcracker wychoski
wycowski's in the chat people
let me see here
[Music]
oh
that was jeremy
oh let's see how's everybody doing out
there
you know we talked about it all weekend
we didn't talk about the chats weekend
chat how you doing let me know
all of you at once yeah report back
report back yep how you doing i see all
of our lovely mods have made it back
home and are moderating oh yeah shout
out to the mods everybody loved the mods
last week yeah that was a big hit we
love the mod yeah thank thank you to you
three again for coming out sorry i
couldn't go party with you at uh
zack show
i heard i missed out sam i was hearing
reports back that a few of you
had a little bit of a rough night a lot
happened a lot happened
you want to elaborate yeah you want to
fill us in a little bit
keep it hello kim uh yeah i mean i got i
got very drunk they cut me off at the
bar but jokes on them because everyone
kept giving me drinks
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know if zack's watching but
i'm sorry i didn't really get to pay
attention to a single song i was just
being passed around like driftwood
throughout the night but i love talking
to people so i was shooting the [ __ ]
with everybody it was a great time and
you know everyone was super sweet have
you ever been cut off at a bar before
was that a first um
no i've gotten cut off once before but
you know
they go to me like this you out you're
out
you're done then like i turn around
and then someone's like cam let me buy
you a drink you know and like i wasn't
even that belligerent or anything i
don't think i i wasn't blackout
um but they were just airing on this you
don't get belligerent when you're drunk
at all you get you get you're the
opposite you get you get lovey-dovey you
get a lovey-dovey but not in a creepy
way yeah i mean i was just i would just
love talking to people sure yeah he was
super chatty on the way home too he kept
saying thanks so much for letting me
crash
yeah okay good yeah slay
but i was busy messing up my lines
oh you are
your play premiered my i was in a play i
played marie antoinette who um gets her
head cut off and actually like
historically
she stepped on the executioner's foot
right before and
said something to the effect of like i
beg your pardon i'm sorry so my line was
i'm so sorry i didn't mean to and
instead i said
i oh my god i am so sorry i forgot and
then the guillotine went
the famous last words marie antoinette
oh my
god historians for years what was she
going to say
[Laughter]
olivia please stand up
i've been listening to olivia the entire
time trump is listening
all right let's get back on the rails
everybody
is that the last time we talk about tate
is this is he done hopefully jesus
be kind of dumb to never even think this
is the 15th minute jesus on his
that's right i like it
i've been enjoying doing social stuff
him i'm not gonna lie dude he gets the
numbers though right love yeah he's just
yeah you know what andrew tate is he's
one of these perfect villains that they
just don't come around that often
you know yeah
that's right
this is like a once a year kind of thing
man it's like a role of a lifetime
true
well let's talk about um
[Music]
world news actually we forgot to give
this uh update our boy
had some hard-hitting stuff
video shows will smith escape away from
a tarantula spider and jumping on a
chair okay i didn't see this
joe bison he really brings me stuff that
i'm not aware of and that's what i love
about him yep
let's see it now he always gets the
scoop
okay okay he is fast
so that's the biggest spider we've ever
seen in our lives yeah yeah
i don't like it at all wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait no this is
a good shot so just stay there
this is a spider in the house this is
this
that's what we're dealing we're selling
the house hello everyone welcome
hey
just watch it now we'll dismiss break it
down for me
arab world news
i'm listening
traps large spider he find is in his
holiday
willie smith
gets afraid of his life and
jumps up on a chair when he sees
a transformer can he jump up on the
chair what's coming he's giving you some
context for what's coming up
in the floor
and let me mr willis smith tell you your
heart is so
light what afraid many people around the
world eating spider as a meal like this
no do not play this man
you're putting strawberries
for this for the gordon [ __ ] um
guaranteed yeah well he ate it oh my god
anyway shout out arab world news
bringing the hard-hitting stories
uh to the top of the
was i understand correctly was he kind
of making fun of will smith for being a
coward for being great yeah dude he
always
yeah
huh
fortnite maybe almost died on twitch
this was i mean bro you need to do
something about this ab
yeah i need to get my life together
here's a b
now what you want to explain this
situation because you took a sip of coke
and then you started choking yeah so i
was taking a break from gaming and lena
brought me some food and i was trying to
eat it real quick and
i felt something stuck in my throat
which happens all the time if i don't
drink and when i went to drink the coke
came back up which happened the first
time i choked and then you could see the
look of death in my eye
what did you eat
what was it was like chicken and rice
so you're slamming chicken down chicken
is it possible you're just not i i think
you're just not chewing bro you know i
wasn't sure but now something
something's wrong
you got a tight little [ __ ] throat
it's a problem
ain't nothing wrong with that am i right
yeah i mean if you widen your throat you
might not choke but i'll tell you what
yeah i gotta figure it out won't be as
fun for me
[Laughter]
but anyway here it is
you're oh my god bro the panic i'm
scared for you you need to fix this you
were so scared
so it went down
it went down yeah but it was a moment of
complete fear so i'm like no way through
this as you're reacting so here we go
your eyes go wide dude you're scared
right
yeah i was terrified
are you joking when you're talking about
choking no dude
this is the you know listen few things
came to my mind and it's weird the way i
think
one i'm like i'm gonna choke i'm gonna
call lena to pull the heimlich and
everyone's gonna say it's fake starting
with love you thought about that yeah
like everyone's gonna say it's fake and
then if i do die
the other option i'm gonna die in an
edward cullen t-shirt
that's a lose-lose that's the way you
would want it a beautiful death
you think it's fake love
not this but if he if he had to have
like someone do the heimlich on
on twitch that'd be that'd be fake
that'd be something
that's cap
you're clearly freaking out so then at
one point you
you you punch your throat that seemed to
work
you slammed your chest uh i don't know
if it was that or just that i backed up
in the way i tilt in my head but
it worked so it went down it went down
i'm dead
they got a life holy snakeys
i'm not even kidding i'm not even
[ __ ] kidding it got stuck
it went down
and now how often do you hear that when
god stuck and went down does he
how often does that happen lena a lot
actually more than you think the other
night too he just randomly woke up i
woke me up too he just he got up like
that and he went like that i did i don't
know what was happening but i
immediately ran and just grabbed him
some water and then i asked him about in
the morning and he didn't remember
that happening or or what was wrong
happening in your sleep that does sound
scary we gotta type we gotta open that
that little throw to yourself
that's hot
yeah
have you ex i wanna go through a throat
enlarging a journey with you on the pot
like where where do we get we could talk
to an earth ear nose throat guy
yeah i talked to one doctor he said it
was fine but i do want to go to a
specialist because it is starting to
scare me
just a little oh when did you see a
doctor about it uh maybe two weeks ago
okay so you so you are being proactive
about it yeah
he looked down your throat
and he's like it's fine he didn't have
any advice for you or anything he like
felt my throat he asked if i've gotten
my thyroid checked which i have and
that's fine
took some blood work
and uh gave me some
pepsi
i think
is that gonna keep you from choking to
death
i don't know this doctor is not you guys
can assume if something happens to me
yeah if you die if you die lena you're
getting paid out though i can't even
post food anymore without people telling
me don't choke
well
one thing that i almost want you to get
there's these things that i used to work
with when i used it worked in elder care
that you put them over your mouth and
then you like pull out like this so you
create a background oh i have that and
that's supposed to be pull out light
block or life that yeah you have one it
actually works like super efficient yeah
so i got one for the kids because i was
so scared about them choking so my
uncle's a doctor i asked him when i was
in michigan what he thought about that
and he said every time someone's afraid
of something people will come out with
stuff like that but he doesn't know how
efficient it is so
i don't know really yeah
all right just die then i mean dr love
said it was efficient yeah did you ever
have to save old people doing that or
have you seen it no but but they said it
was you a useful thing to know because
it does happen
yeah
all right well uh uh maybe we're wishing
you well i'm still here [ __ ] yeah
you're still here
he has a lot of enemies trying to take
him out
enemies everywhere
chicken yo andrew
sends his regards
chunk of chicken
a big old piece of chicken
breast dried chicken breast
uh it tastes like beef jerky dan was
talking mad [ __ ] on rottweilers if you
guys recall a few episodes it wasn't
really mad [ __ ] well you said they were
dangerous freak animals i didn't use the
word freak i believe you said they're
little demons that nobody should own
here
i remember now i did say that you're
right here's one of our fans response to
you dan
that is
so awesome i love that
because this is what my dog rosa thinks
of dan's rottweiler slander
so good
that was i did not put my dick anywhere
near my dog
good well that would explain why he's
attacking humans if jordan peterson's
been
violating oh
i did not come on my dog
well
i'd like to believe you you're a lion
dog faced pony soldier wait okay so so
what is this what's up everybody
my secret surgery
oh is this a throat enlargement yeah
oh we could learn so much ab we could
my secret surgery
you got a fat [ __ ] throat hole bro we
should learn together
yeah he got a big
let's see let's go to the most um
wait is this like a serious operation
mercury oh no maybe
hold on i'm coming
[Music]
okay all right chris here we go
by the way this video has 12 million
views man it was so different back then
people didn't even watch jeffree star
anymore really do they
uh people do but not that he's
definitely lost traction like if i go
what's up everybody his last video has
six hundred thousand
he definitely fell off that's
interesting maybe maybe if you vlog it
you'll get 12 mil maybe
yeah that looks um
a little scary i'm not gonna lie
uh it's gross
yeah i drove you guys down my handbag
okay um
oh my god
good morning
[Music]
but if you do do it it's a good content
opportunity
that's what it is
[Laughter]
if jeffrey's best he also got it
this place has been marked i will look
violated forever
maybe zap will get it to throw in large
with the uab
hell yeah show off solid yeah
all right thank you that's enough
jeffree star
yes sir
um
let's see
jordan pearson's crying again i would
have never seen this coming what
i s this clip is so funny
this man is so [ __ ] up it's just so
why gnarly
um
[Music]
here just watch it is there anything
more fundamental than pain
love
wait hold on there's a longer clip that
that i feel like is
shows it better [ __ ] you longer clip of
this
i watched that whole podcast and it was
painful
was it all super awkward man
well at first i thought maybe he's still
capable of having like
a somewhat interesting conversation but
like literally on every single point he
he has these kind of moments where he
goes up like stares out in the [ __ ]
horror song and like just thinks about
something and says something so [ __ ]
cringe you you think he's like
discover something great to say and then
he's
he comes back and like
sets the
[ __ ] back up precisely or something i
like lex friedman though it's pretty
cool you like that guy okay i don't know
i don't know much about him i just
recognized his face here i think this is
the longer clip you're talking about oh
thank you yeah the whole thing is just
incredible adils yeah i think this is i
think this is it
what was it that i said
yeah here we go
matter isn't dead dust
i don't know what it is
i have no idea what it is matter is what
matters there's a definition dude he's
reverted to a 13 year old and i'm deep
[ __ ] jordan peterson
great thinker of all time just said
matter matters
what is matter
i don't know what does it do i do i
think that might be out of your realm of
expertise [ __ ] you i don't understand
what matter is
what matters in these increasingly
strange days
matter is what matters there's a
definition that's a very weird
definition
that would be a horrible definition
what's real
matter it's like okay that's one answer
what's real
what matters is real
because that's how you act
okay that's different than matter
it's like okay what's the most real of
what matters
how about pain
why is it the most real
try arguing it away
good luck
so pain is the fundamental reality
all right i'm just going to let it play
i'm gonna let it play and then we can
watch and comment because it deserves to
be played on its own okay
well that's rough
doesn't that lead to nihilism and
hopelessness
yeah doesn't it lead to a philosophy
that's antithetical towards being the
most fundamental reality is pain
yes
is there anything more fundamental than
pain
love
this man needs help
laughing truth
that's what you got
and you know
and that's that if they're more powerful
than pain
maybe they're the most real things
bro you worried about him
lost bro you should be worried about him
it's time to stop the cameras and ask if
he needs help yeah he is not doing well
that's what i'm saying they keep
parading him around i mean i feel like
at a certain point these conservative
grifters are using someone who's not
well and it's becoming it's becoming
problematic like
to be bringing this guy out crying about
matter matters i mean what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
i think contextually because you know he
has
he's
a deeply spiritual man as he talks about
all the time and uh you know he hates
the jews
post-modernism and uh you know
materialism and stuff and i think he's
trying to like undercut the argument
about like uh like realist philosophy
about matter and everything but it's
just so
confused uh
the point that he's trying to make
as always he just breaks out into crying
halfway through which
just seems to be every interview that he
does nowadays winds up with him tearing
up
halfway through so
i don't know
[ __ ]
yeah so i i like he goes
he goes what what's the most powerful
thing
pain
i was like what you just picked that at
random you just picked that emotion at
random
i think you're in a lot of pain
it's the most real for
him his life is pain this this is just
basically almost like incoherent
psychobabbo because that's how you act
okay that's different than matter
it's like okay
it's different than matter okay
what are men made out of semen
and muscles
is that what matters
yes
matter is seem in a muscle
and
pain okay so pain matters
we've figured that out
but you know what matters more than pain
and common muscles
love
what is love
okay we've defined pain
but what is love
it's also common muscles
and that matters
and that
matters more
i'm not seeing enough tears out of you
for this to be a proper come on i'm not
seeing enough tears yeah let's get some
come on everybody watch
out here
you know what really matters i'm not
seeing a lot of movement
at one point did he start crying that's
why i don't understand it was so instant
i really lost it that's exactly the word
love and then
i've been i've been places in my life
where i'm that unstable and i'm like
crying at everything and i'm just like a
[ __ ] mess emotionally
but i like when i went to college before
i was medicated or like in therapy
i was like a mess things like small
things i would be in tears i remember i
was like at a movie theater watching
some movie
and i was just like
sobbing uncontrollably spy kids yes spy
kids man it's so tragic what happened to
them i have a story exactly like that
when i was switching um my medications i
think i did it improperly and like the
tapering was messed up and i knew that
something was wrong when i was sitting
in the kitchen and my parents were
watching the bee gees documentary and i
wasn't even paying attention i literally
wasn't even listening i don't know
anything about the bee gees i heard one
i heard the narrator say that like his
brother had died and i lost my mind
i was like
you know his brother died and i like i
was something needs to change and
right that is what this reminds me of so
i've been there and it's like a deeply
unstable emotionally unwell place right
it was like nothing could make me feel
better and i couldn't understand that it
wasn't affecting me
so you guys aren't psychiatric helpless
like
telling people how to live their lives
yeah exactly but no i just i'm just i'm
trying to explain where he this
emotional state that i see him in but it
is extra ironic considering he has a phd
in psychology or
psychology i was thinking during this
podcast you can see he he has like some
iq there's something underneath
everything but then there's this layer
of just sorrow or like sadness and
emotion on top that just ruins it all
so when he when he was
coming on the scene and was super
popular he was articulate he was
thoughtful he was very smart i mean he
has a great way of weaving things
together
telling great stories and but but since
he basically you know
went to russia and got a blood
transfusion for some crazy experimental
treatment for benzo addiction
his mind it's just all unhinged man or
the meat diet too that can't be helping
the meat diet cannot be helping his
emotional state who cares what you
believe the the meat diet was a
was a symptom not a cause
you know what i mean well you know like
to me that's like part of the erratic
behavior of like i'm just gonna
start slamming [ __ ] t-bones some say
it was the apples the sip of apples
[ __ ]
but it's interesting when he talks about
his almighty diet he says it cured him
he says it's cured his mental clearly
yeah he seems great
he's doing great now but seriously at
what point do these people really need
to like be more concerned about him as a
human being
well
they won't i love this clip though
what's the most well yeah ben shapiro
that the and the daily wires like yo
this guy's super unstable let's get him
let's give him give him a whole lot
that's what i was going to say is
the opposite seems to be the case
exactly
totally most real of what matters
how about pain
pain why is it the most real
try arguing it away
he answers his own question so bad why
is pain the most real
try arguing that away bucko
you can't do it
it's pain it sounds like he's doing like
spoken word poetry of like a talking
head song or something
[Laughter]
and you might find yourself
living in a beautiful house
taking the pain away and you may ask
yourself well
how did i get here
[Laughter]
he does a lot of these hand motions to
it
that's so good that's so true isn't it
very dave dave burn inspired
good luck good luck bach so pain is the
fundamental reality how'd you get to
that how did you leap from that
pain
there's time space and pain
matter is made up from calm muscles and
pain
love would you like some of my [ __ ]
and love
this man is so [ __ ] up all right
well that's rough that's wrong doesn't
that lead to nihilism and hopelessness
talk about the allegations
philosophy that's antithetical towards
being the most fundamental reality is
pain yes
is there anything more fundamental than
people
love
love yo i don't know this is one of my
favorite jordan peterson moments for
sure
what was the reception of this podcast
were the comments kind of like uh oh you
know how his fans are that's what i mean
this is this is incredible this is the
deepest conversation
no so happy i think they're good yeah i
think they're very good
oh people love it okay i said i love it
they love it
battle not really
if you're in pain
you're in pain
absolutely fantastic podcast and
interview this was both lex friedman and
jordan peterson at their best the longer
interview really helped get any vestiges
of the boilerplate out of the way and
allowed the conversation to go much
deeper than usual by the end it was like
watching two old friends talk oh my god
top comment on the video that's absurd
all right well shout out you guys follow
your kings andrew tate and jordan
peterson will lead you to the promised
land the intellectual promised land
uh
here's another clip this guy had all the
i had all the great clips here let's
take a look at this one
so i have the question
the question might be something like
put your
put your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world
okay
what does that mean exactly put you what
does house mean
what does put
what does that mean that active
verb what does perfect an order mean
chill bro some money today
he's like he's he's questioning like
theater what does put mean
what does mean mean he does it all day
and you know but jordan you're a grown
ass man
before you criticize the world what does
it mean to criticize what does it mean
to criticize the world how can you do
that properly or improperly so i have
the question broach
i love what does put mean
what does that mean exactly put what
does house mean
what does put
what does put mean that active
huh
this guy is so [ __ ] really drilling
into it dude he's been talk he's been
saying the same thing for like five six
years now it's not that [ __ ] deep
clean your house yeah i mean well
confucius said that i mean he didn't
even people have been using that
expression for literally thousands of
years
confucius said like make sure your bed
mat is
tidy before you can tidy your life or
something you know something similar
um
also his house is dirty as [ __ ]
my seed is all over this the life of you
jordan peterson makes a startling
confession uh-oh yeah
will the globalists take the life of
your children it's very likely if you're
dutch ask yourself why i have a message
for birds stop flying if you dare i'll
splash you with icy and salty slush as i
drive by in my ford bronco suv existing
is pain don't you think gamers are
rising up as they
should the planet will descend into
chaos this will devastate australia
emergency we have to make everyone
poorer now i should have
all the money critics of my view will
say we if we leave the poor horror life
will be more difficult and less
rewarding this would be good how do we
know delusional thinking did you watch
the better call
finale
here is the confession i killed 40
hookers and made
that is a confession really
[Laughter]
shout out to very tall bart
[Music]
yes felt like that made like
that was a favor to jordan that made him
sound more sane
more coherent
jordan peterson clip right there yeah
you're in the chat uh what's up ela she
says love listening to my favorite
podcast
[ __ ] my top l
wait let me look at the chat what the
[ __ ]
ela says loving listening to my favorite
pokemon not funny love my top l lad el
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] you
yeah so here's there's more i mean i
love i don't know how you guys feel but
i love it
i trust lomberg
trust tupi
trust matt ridley
they thought about these things deeply
they're not just saying oh the
environment doesn't matter whatever the
environment is
you know the environment i don't even
know what that is that's everything the
environment well to be fair you don't
even know what put means
you know
you're still struggling with matter what
matters matters
that was some serious [ __ ]
i loved it like
he's so
he's just so overwhelmed with
meaning and importance and then the
environment he's like the environment
that [ __ ] ridiculous [ __ ]
he just went down the meme hole of right
wing talking points why does jordan
peterson even have an opinion about the
environment you know what i mean because
he's part of the daily wire
the environment [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'll shoo how dare you tell me
how to treat this whatever treat means
whatever mean means
what means
mean mean
so grunting
matter whatever
the environment is
you know the environment i don't even
know what that is that's everything the
environment i'm concerned about the
environments like
which is how is that different than
saying i'm worried about everything
[ __ ] it has a specific definition you
dumbass you don't have to get like
like the environment bro
just google it i don't know
just use the definition here the
surrounding or conditions in which a
person animal or plant lives and
operates damn that's that wasn't that
[ __ ] up was it dude didn't even know
that was so easy to define actually
you're a phd
how are you real bro this take on the
environment
the environment i don't even know what
that is that's everything the
environment i'm concerned about the
environments like
talk about the alligators
yes this is why i'm watching
wow there's a lot of these this is great
here there's more here
i'm i'm loving this man why do you care
right
let me ask you about
the famine of the 30s yeah
do you think ukraine in the ukraine oh
yeah
fun fun fun similar fun fun fun
it tastes like beef jerky it tastes like
cheeses
chill i didn't really hit it twice
one of the things you mentioned in the
last few sentences kind of echo to that
part of human history holding
there's more
usb okay so
this sounds pretty crazy blast for
example is no longer
at
replacement with regard to birth rate it
means we've abandoned the virgin and the
child in the most fundamental sense it's
a bloody catastrophe what the [ __ ] is
the virgin in the child is there some
biblical [ __ ] yeah uh jesus and mother
mary so what is jesus what does that
have to do with jesus mother mary
well he's just saying like
humanity's most sacred duty is to
procreate essentially and that we've
well why is he gonna stay like that
because he's jordan peterson he goes
obtuse and weird impossible about
everything in the child anal sex when
just say we have to have more kids
we gotta talk like in that like a
psychobabble what matters
children
sexual desire of any sort what matter
makes children
come
i have the great luxury of coming
there's more emergency dragon
there's a dragon oh someone comes oh no
he's talking about the problem
with it
that's what the environmentalists say
the radical types who push limits to
growth then i look at them and i think
okay
is that dragon real or not
why should i listen to you
well let's see how you're reacting i was
so [ __ ] up on xanax once i saw a
literal dragon
i found myself asking
is that dragon real i was watching
house of the dragon last night
100 milligrams of benzos i saw the
dragon in my living room
is it was it a real dragon
no
but did i love the dragon
yes
into the dragon first of all you're
scared stiff and in the state of panic
that might indicate you're not the man
for the job
dude this man is up on the verge he's
got one foot in the grave
like seriously maybe this man helped
feed this man a [ __ ] tomato or
something
vitamin c his body is failing
you're scared stiff and in a state of
panic
that might indicate you're not the man
for the job [ __ ] second
you're willing to use compulsion to
harness other people to fight the dragon
for you
so now not only are you terrified you're
a terrified tyrant
so then i would say well then you're not
the moses that we need to lead us out of
this particular exodus i'm sorry there's
no [ __ ] way
that people listen to this and we're
like
that man
this is the best jordan's ever been he's
not even coherent he speaks in like
metaphors like non-stop metaphors it's
just not a good way to communicate you
can't mix metaphors i miss the part of
the bible where moses is fighting
dragons though that like melissa is free
right that's what i'm saying you can't
mix metaphors bro you got to stick with
one
otherwise it gets too sloppy this was by
far
my favorite conversation between two
human beings
i feel so lucky to have listened in a
way thank you both no
how many views does it have
uh a million one million
okay that's not a that's not like an
existential crisis
a million i can live with
if i had 20 or something i'd be worried
1.3 so then i would say well then you're
not the moses that we need to lead us
out of this particular exodus
there's a dragon
but then moses comes in
we need moses to lead us away from the
dragon
and spread the seas
like king david
like alexander the great you cut
the cube in half
and then we got to get the dragon
and spread the sea wait
i'm moses
okay now i'm alexander
we need to conquer this dragon
with our own dragon we need our own
dragon we need our own have you guys
seen the game of the new house of
dragons
very good show
but as i was saying
let's say someone asked me a question in
in the youtube comments said why why why
can i trust your advice on the
environmental front
that is a great question
why the [ __ ] would i listen to jordan
peterson on environmental
and i say
what is what is listening
what is
listening what is what is is
is
i just can't believe he's getting into
like in climate change denial now like
where did that even come from dude
[ __ ]
this was
and i don't say this lightly
the best conversation
i've ever heard of the doc as a guest
lex did a huge favor to j
jbp followers in this video
play though we are uh oh
domestic terrorists yeah yeah
go ahead ab
any any moment now maybe
nope
you got it folks
one more time
okay here we go
ladies and gentlemen we are all demet
all right you know what we didn't quite
make it to the end but you just forget
it we got it yeah flocka
that's really good question
okay
let's see if we can figure out the
principles by which the advice would be
trustworthy okay how how do you know
it's not trustworthy
well
one
potential
response to that would be the claims are
not in accordance with the facts but you
know facts are tricky things and it
depends on where you look for them so it
depends how you define depends
the facts are tricky things
i'm just spitting facts you know
sometimes the facts is like gepetto
you build
you try to build a real boy
but he gets swallowed by a whale
and inside the whale
you find the excalibur
right like king arthur
no
but it's shattered
like aragorn sword like in a book
must be reforged
and and it's like you come out like
moses spreading the sea
and and it's all just too much
because you're the first one on the moon
just like neil armstrong you're up there
all alone
it's like
it's like geppetto said
i wish i had a real boy
jiminy cricket it's like geppetto said
this porridge is too hot but this one is
just right
you know uh the the fable of the three
bears is really
says a lot
and it's like she and it's like she went
in there to taste the porridge but
instead
she found a big swamp
and it was shrek and donkey
i must say that i've had some
post-coital regrets about that phrase
that's a tough one to get right because
for example lomberg's fundamental
critics argue about his facts not just
his interpretation of them so this guy
goes he goes someone left why should i
listen to you about environmental [ __ ]
and he said well that's a good question
because facts and what's facts are
tricky and well this one guy about this
one thing said this bro you got nothing
to say i'm trying to make a point
well and it he so quickly i don't know
if you if i caught it completely
correctly but it's it was like what if
what if somebody said that to you and
then within
two sentences he's like
three guys deep into a hypothetical back
and forth it's the inception of uh right
it's just like you don't well but then
he would say this but then somebody
might say this to that and it's just
like what do you say it's the inside
that's the question of of podcasting or
something or i don't know thinking i
mean
the man's inceptioning himself into a
black hole of [ __ ] nothingness
yes
you know how can anyone watch this and
think this is an interesting
intellectual conversation is just sad
the
mob that can't be an unerring guide and
so i thought well the facts
exactly doesn't work
because when it's about i thought i will
ask a climate scientologist and then i
said [ __ ] that
but i did not because what is climate
and what is a scientist
and then i thought
it rains a lot in pinocchio when the
flood comes
well that's climate
and to that someone would say
it rains a lot in pinocchio
and so
we have to consider that
and you
know
this he just goes on this morning i had
a pretty bad diarrhea
so there's that to consider
i use baby wipes they say they clog the
drains
does anybody figure that into their
equation
who has to go fix those drains
these poor men these sewer workers
so to answer your question yes people
should listen to me about the
environment
whatever that means
everything there's too many facts
facts so then how do you do that i've
figured out his cadence whatever that
means
we got to think about the facts
he speeds up real fast he emphasizes
that
even if someone's a trustworthy guide
guys of the apocalyptic unknown because
that's really the question [ __ ]
should they listen to you on climate
and the answer is
they're not terrified tyrants
i think that's the answer
bro
that's the answer to what nobody
that's the answer to no one's question
nobody asked dude nobody asked hey what
an amazing gift to all your listeners
this tops the list as far as interviews
with important thinkers thank you so
much for sharing this interview with
your audience i will listen again and be
inspired oh my god were these people
even listening
or were they like doing something else
in the background
if you're not actually listening it
sounds like a very clever conversation
yeah right yeah but if you actually like
what the [ __ ] is he saying
[Laughter]
god damn
this was heaven
literally my two favorites in the last
few years and nobody before them
wow
oh my god you said god is there's a new
one
uh here he believes
he uses logic
to uh prove god exists and we have
killed him and will not find enough
water to wash away all the blood so that
was nietzsche he's no fool he's got away
with words he certainly does
and so then you think okay well we
killed the transcendent
well
what does that mean for science well it
frees it up because all that nonsense
about a deity is just the idiot
superstition that stops the scientific
um
what process from moving forward that's
basically the new atheist claim
something like that it's like wait a
second
do you believe in the transcendent if
you're a scientist
and the answer is
well not only do you believe in it you
believe in it more than anything else
because if you're a scientist this guy
he poses questions to himself and then
answers them yep
it's a great way to make you sound like
you have an interest
well let me ask you this well wait a
minute
what did you eat for breakfast
well the answer is pancakes
i'm trying to think but nothing happens
you believe in
what objects to your theory
more than you believe in your theory now
we've got to think that through very
carefully so your theory describes the
world and as far as you're concerned
your description of the world is the
world
but because you're a scientist you think
well even though that's my description
of the world and that's what i believe
there's something beyond what i believe
and that's the object and so i'm going
to throw my theory against the object
and see where it'll break random and
then i'm going to use the evidence of
the break
as a source of new information to
revitalize my theory so as a scientist
you have to posit these nobody's
following this i'm like
i'm curious where this is going because
all right
he's saying here we go existence of the
ontological transcendent before you can
move forward at all
but more
you have to pause it that contact with
the ontological transcendent
annoying though it is because it upsets
your apple cart is exactly what will in
fact set you free
so then you accept the proposition that
there is a transcendent reality shut the
[ __ ] up it's so stupid
are you asking a logical question but
that transcendent reality is redemptive
in the most fundamental now you have to
ask yourself bring the back i love that
ian bring that back you have to ask
yourself
where is my apple cart going
and is it stopping before
the donkey
with the bird the beast of burden
and the beasts we feel for the beasts
because well they're beasts but what is
a beast
the beast gets the beauty
the beast did get the beauty so is it a
beast or a prince
and i go back to the apple cart
and i take a bite of the apple the apple
of knowledge
you know adam
he took a bite of an apple
that didn't turn out so good did it
[Laughter]
and eve well she's just a brib
she's not even really a whole person
this is awesome here's the last one
let's watch it
death your own
who knows how often do you gaze upon
death your own yeah this guy knew this
guy's reading
he sees the writing on the wall how
often do you think about it
because it's right around the corner bro
and we all know it
like
like this is his effort to be like yo
are you okay this is intervention yeah
this is the best they can do to
intervene very soon you go to hell so
how often do you think about death
jordan peterson
who knows how often do you gaze upon
death your own
how often do you
remember remind yourself that this ride
ends perf personally personally
all the time literally every second of a
deep thinker
he knows man he knows he's not well
[Laughter]
like
he could be healthy and like
live a long time
but
something is going deeply wrong like the
meat the benzos there's just his body is
not surviving well
he's putting the rat the wrong gas in
the [ __ ] tank you know what i mean
shatteringly insightful conversation
thank you both for expressing yourself
so fully and truthfully it was a
pleasure to watch and listen shattering
shatteringly insightful man jordan
peterson wrote that
i know it's a bisque uh bisque quick uh
knife
a great thinker all right
as a as a deep thinker and philosopher
it's easy to start philosophizing
and forgetting that you're
you might die angel of death sits on
every word
he's always right behind me i think
about death constantly
the angel of death sits on every word i
say
and every morning i take a benzo and i
wonder is this my last
what is last
what is benzo
benzo sounds like bend
am i bending over to pick up my benzo
no
no
it's on the table
i don't have to bend
anyway i'm gonna die
how's that
i how often do you actually consciously
all the time
uh notice the angel all the time dude
he's crying out for help please
literally man i think it's one of the
things that made me he's literally the
dude from
the seventh seal he just has the grim
reaper just like following him
swedish we were right it is a swedish
shout out bergman dude it's a bergman
that's a that's a bergman joint
please help him guys you're not
listening he's crying for help
i think about death constantly
it haunts my every thought
it's the first thing on my mind and the
last thing on my mind before i go to
sleep
i see the i see you
you look like the angel of death please
help please help me that's very
interesting jordan anyway
this is me asking for help
i'm begging you please stop using me so
what do you think about trans kids yes
yep [ __ ]
freaks
it's the angel all the time
i think it's one of the things that made
me
peculiar
when i was in graduate school you know i
thought about i was
i had the thought of death in my mind
all the time
and i noticed that many of the people
that i was with these were people i
admired fine they that wasn't part of
their character but it was definitely
part of mine i'd wake up every morning
this happened for years think
time short get at it time short get at
it
there's things to do
and so and then okay so after
the lecture we play a piece of music
that is a piece of music that i've been
producing with some musicians for
a couple of books i'm going to release
in the fall terrible books abc of
childhood tragedy they're called dark
dark books it's 14 pages
comical books
terrible books
heartbreaking illustrations can't wait
to read them
[Laughter]
can't wait for the audiobooks
yeah thank you you got a cliff notes
version could check out or anything
thank you gabby r
uh she has some messages she says ab uh
soundsimp you still have a lot to learn
oh wow harsh yeah no [ __ ] you should
have saved your money
oh come on okay
come on amy i mean you do have been
doing this for an hour and a half you
can't have that much emotional
investment scott says sending love to
the h3 fam all the way from chicago god
bless you
um today is my 25th birthday can i get a
shout out alyssa h happy birthday let's
[ __ ] go right now
happy birthday
vlog you got here here's what you get
from us
[Applause]
ah i don't know why it's not yeah and
then there's one more here or okay
whatever you guys gotta help me out with
that it's not easy to navigate
when we're live
yeah but that that basically is uh
so the good the good parts there
fun huh
love it always love dunking on this guy
he sucks
um
let me see if there's oh god i mean it's
already four but
i'm never going to get to this [ __ ]
tick tock or this
trailer let's talk about it on wednesday
yeah
yes
it's going to be good you guys want to
see yeezy's gap [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i do
get in line [ __ ] fun this man is
selling this it's just unfolded like
that
literally just shoved into a [ __ ] bag
well when i went to the store the guy
was like frantically folding it there
was one dude just folding it and he's
like please if you know what you want
just tell me the size i'll grab it from
back oh yeah
that is just a [ __ ]
bag of [ __ ]
in israel they use these bags to haul
like sand
it's just wild to me
um
the easy gap line has now released in
stores across the country many are
criticizing the display
that it looks like trash bags kanye's
proposal for the display was that the
big bends would make things easier
for customers to sift through find their
size are you serious
yeah he doesn't actually think that does
he you ain't got the answers i mean this
is obviously a way way way way way
less convenient way of shopping yeah
there's a video clip of him talking
about it it's pretty short but it's in
there
does he think because there's nothing in
the back then people can just
see he doesn't really get to that part
he's just pretty defensive about it
honestly
it's horrible
i mean it looks like trash you don't
want to spend a lot of money on
something that looks like trash
and it's all wrinkled and [ __ ] have you
have any of you guys seen this in person
or got your hands on it i have yeah yeah
i felt bad there was this one guy that
was like frantically folding them and
there was a little cart next to it and
he goes there's a lot of sizes there if
you just know what you want and he was
going around just four bins they're
right in the front of the store just
trying to arrange everything i felt
about everyone were the other people
checking it out were people buying this
stuff you know a lot of people were
checking it out everyone was stopping in
i don't know how many were like easy
fans how many people were like what the
[ __ ] is this there's four big-ass
garbage bags in the front of the store
maybe i thought it was a sale did you
cop a feel how did it look
the quality was good yeah real nice
interesting
he made it very clear these are not
trash bags they're construction bags
here he is explaining
do you understand
some people felt that putting clothes in
bags is insensitive perhaps to homeless
and other people that is [ __ ] dumb
that is like bro yeah that is so dumb
come on dude it's all dub dumb well yeah
of course he's defensive this is the
dumbest thing i've ever heard and
sensitive to homeless people
bro if you care about homeless people go
give them food they don't give a [ __ ]
about a gap bag idiot they got bigger
problems than that
idiot
what an idiot
god no wonder
this is how the right wins elections by
the way
it's a dumb
these are pictures you took abe yeah
h3 podcast exclusives right in the front
of the store
i felt bad for this couple that i
randomly just got a creep shot on but
yeah it doesn't look as messy as that
one photo but there's no way that these
are going to be such a mess when you get
it out there yeah the next big choice
now you can see there's a little cart
that the guy put next to
the bags oh he's tried to fold them yeah
120 bucks
what is it it's just a shirt
yeah a short sleeve shirt for 120. look
at the gap
whoa
is that the price that's a short sleeve
shirt from the gap 120.
maybe that's not how many there is the
prices are insane yo give me that link i
want to see
i mean the gap is not an expensive store
right i mean they're like mid-range
mid-range i mean they're affordable
let's be hon they're affordable prices
so let's see dude that's a [ __ ] shirt
is 120 bucks
everything's like a crop top
yeah
no fatties allowed
uh what else you got
cargo pants 220
long sleeve 120 what's this hoodie dove
hoodie
240
sheesh
tank top 80 bucks [ __ ]
keep going
golly
red
i don't know man
i don't know who's buying this [ __ ]
i never seen anyone wear this stuff
i think the whole body i'm not gonna
drop that much money on it though
yo yeah yeah exactly what what is he
doing he's selling a body suit
it's morphing what's the market for this
wait where's the hole at
the back is the back
you just
you just climb in from the hole
what are we doing here uh yeezy go back
i want to see the price
this could be yours for 300 bucks
engineered by balenciaga man i don't
care if it's engineered by the pulp i
ain't putting that [ __ ] on
man this is just kind of surreal
yo look at that look at the silhouette
on those pants
where those look like goddamn like
like adventure time the dog the long
legs
who's fitting in those pants
it's like if you're on stilts
i've already taken my pants off
what the [ __ ] are those
it's like slender's man's pants
i'm really hung up on the snake bag
right now go back let's hold that up dan
i want to see that snake bag
okay what am i looking at
it's just
stop
it's literally just like a tube
is there a place to put stuff in
it better be i'm trying to find it it's
so thin
this man is just trying to put your ass
in a [ __ ] sleeping bag
everything's just sleeping bag
oh the zipper goes like all the way
around
all right how sick this is so weird
you want 80 flame gap cap i know it's
such a thing as gap is kind of like
preppy
i don't think of it as like fashion
forward at all
this is very interesting
i notice everything's in stock
oh yeah
yeah they were fully stocked in person
too they don't think anything was sold
[ __ ] you now dude
such a weird world
a good time to remind everyone
oh now go on down to christchurch.com
thank you dan wonderful
look at all those beautiful designs
colorful
fun look 45 conventional 45 [ __ ]
dolls you know that might sound a lot
but this shirt is custom hand dyed
yeah we just saw a 120 dollar shirt that
doesn't even fit and doesn't even have a
design on it it has an embroidery and
it's custom hand dyed so wow there's a
lot of work there it is
actually a lot of work on that shirt
i like what this our stuff looks
colorful and fun by the way click the
charming story t i wrote this
uh this one yeah read it it's it's
[ __ ] dope this is nice this is uh go
down here
zoom in
bear
wanted shoes
so he went to his closet he looked at
boots
he looked at high heels this is like one
of jordan peterson's metaphors he looked
at high heels
he looked at tap shoes
he looked at disemboweled rabbit
what should i wear he's wondered
i want shoes said bear
i do not want boots or heels or tap
shoes or a disembowelled rabbit
i've got it realized bear
i'll just go barefoot with my bare feet
that was some serious [ __ ] you reading
theodore a lot a lot of books it was
just some corny thing it was based on
some
i like it some other
some vintage shirt that it kind of looks
like those like funny text chains that
go around
right right right it's like early bloody
october let's go
how many am i
gobbling down a pumpkin or i don't know
yeah i love those olivia
yes
um okay shout out yeezy i guess go get a
king or whatever
or something like that or something go
get something
cool
cool guys good morning man great
that's what i think there we go exactly
sums up my thoughts nicole rogers
donated fifty dollars and said i use my
free super chat the other day to send
this but i wanted to send an actual one
to let you know that listening to you
uh when you did the heimlich
demonstration saved my daughter's life
dude that's true later that day
dude that's two lives we've saved just
from super chat just wanted to say
thanks wow
god bless
waving seeing more waiting comments like
that
way more
maybe
maybe we need to do more life-saving
psas someone saved me
i mean
[ __ ] we're saving lives here
how else do people die that
you can be saved like that droning some
people drowning oh yeah well like you
mean like cpr yeah
yeah we could do cpr some cpr training
um
avoiding apple cider i hear a lot of
just put it down yeah put the apples put
the apple cider down do you guys want to
light me on fire we can have some fun
with that just stop drop and roll yeah
let's have fun with that self-defense
isn't there like a self-defense guy
that's trending or like was trending oh
yeah i tried to reach out to him he's
from detroit
oh you weren't able to get uh oh he's
the first email he responded but not the
second i know a good self-defense
place here i've taken i think like two
oh interesting oh oh i know how we could
do this i have my friend who is a
detroit cop who's coming to stay with us
in two weeks no he's
he could teach us he was teaching me how
to disarm someone the other day so maybe
because he know where acab
oh yeah he's cool he's down
he's down
i'd love to talk to a detroit cop
yeah he's seen some [ __ ]
20 minutes ago
oh my god arab world news reacts to
andrew tape
i'm curious what really curious this is
the take we need to we need to hear for
sure on my channel again
can you turn it up a little bit uh i got
it the short message to andrew tyler
because when i look on internet i found
his name
all time
so i wanna tell him
woman is half society without here we
can't alive right the human beings will
be gone and disappear
imagine close your eyes imagine
i think you don't have name android type
or have accounts on social media or
mother
produce you
you must respect and appreciate them not
hate
them
if you have a problem with your
girlfriend
you should fix it and not hate all the
woman for all the way i mean air world
news
mad facts
so based i mean dude thumbs up based
and blue pill you don't miss you don't
miss no that was a that was a good come
with that heat
yeah
all right well how long have we been
going dan
uh
it will be three hours standby standby
wow stand by
give it one more second here
five
four
three
two
one
three hours
three hours
all right
cool
well basically there's um
uh oh apparent so either went on
christina p's podcast
she confronted her on something eh
between a six and an eight like you're a
medium ela went in on christina
well ela had a base take i did that
okay base take it's a funny moment she
roasted mm-hmm
you're not just i come from i don't look
at myself with reality goggles
i don't like like okay like when i go to
adidas what size are you shh
you're not mama's just i'm petite and
you are i'm just like i'm barely a size
two i'm just like i'd float between a
six and an eight like you're a medium
and uh so you kind of like don't you're
not size models i don't wanna see go to
a d
like when i go to adidas.com which is an
athletic
clothing company and they have like
plus size
women and i'm like i don't want to buy
that i i will i will literally click off
of it because i'm like i don't want to
be fat
it makes me feel like i get and it's not
her i'm saying the feeling in me that
goes i don't want to be over
if i buy that i'll be overweight do you
understand even though that's not for me
i agree that that's a plus size
item
i go i go it's like bad juju or
something like oh god i'll be fat if i
wear that i mean that's interesting
that's i mean that's my like stupidity
yeah that sounds like i got metal
carvings
[Laughter]
you're stupid
i just want to say
christina is a close and dear friend of
mine and those two gals are very close
friends so i want anyone to interpret
this as
anything other than friends ribbing
around they're very friendly they're
very close
also on that note some people seem to be
confused when they were on the adidas
website i played the
heavyvisitblack.com
just that was a soundbite just to be
clear have you have you visited black
maybe randomly ask christina
you know
i saw the opening because they were
going adidas.com
and ela wasn't talking so i'm like
stupid i [ __ ] know no it's up short
tights
up
i mean down scroll it down so that the
page goes up yeah just a little either
savage either compilation
got a vibe
you're the savage moment compilation
yeah uh what else we got here so there's
triller
there's about on wednesday
[ __ ] hell bro we're gonna have to
open with this someday
wednesday
man it is wednesday man
it's like the pewdiepie me
yeah
yeah people have wednesdays by next week
oh let's go
um
okay i guess that's it
well and then there's the bizarre
tick-tock claim that says they're fusing
animals together
i don't know that that one's that
interesting talk about the allegations
i for real dude you've been putting this
off
for so long
the trailer allegations no
your allegations
but the the yeah we'll dress it up you
have nothing well addressed on wednesday
oh my god
uh
okay let's just call it a day then we
got we'll have some fun stuff on
wednesday i just can't wait to go in on
ryan cav cav he's just been coasting
along too long for too long now oh we're
having 10 brian kavanagh as a force of
nature we're having tim on wednesday
i'm far something here even what we're
having tim on wednesday
oh [ __ ] so we're not gonna be able to do
anything we planned let's talk to him
about triller
okay has he heard the whole ryan
kavanagh thanks son i don't think he has
so we could you know have a whole
presentation yeah i like the opportunity
to educate new people on that yeah
exactly
yeah i liked him he's funny did anyone
watch the special
uh me and kim did did you like it yeah
we thought it was good okay i i can't
speak for cam cam did you like it that
was all right we didn't finish it so i
gotta i gotta finish it yeah we had like
20 minutes left
and i was also hungover watching it too
so
it was hard to pay attention
did you guys hate it dan says you're
lying you hated it too much wine sorry
you hated it what no we loved it
i mean you could you don't have to lie
to me no we liked it we liked it we
loved it don't say that dan he's a
[ __ ] hater bro
wait
10 the [ __ ]
well that's not here somebody needs to
be a little joker brand yeah i got it
right here
is that a i'm confused did you guys hate
it
are you just is it awkward because he's
coming on wednesday
that you don't want to admit you didn't
like it
aby's type
[Music]
[ __ ] you baby
av uh
wait you play you play the [ __ ] you
maybe
what whatever is that what you did you
played the [ __ ] a b soundbite wow
in my head
i thought it was funny i don't know what
y'all are on about it was funny man
i guess you guys are more kind of jeff
dunham guys or what
i thought it was all right i didn't hate
it you didn't even finish it i didn't
yeah i didn't hate it though
i'll make sure tim knows that you guys
are the haters okay yeah i'll warn them
about you guys sounds good
and i'll i'll have to finish it too
maybe it has a grand finale that i me
that we missed but i was hungover at the
time too so that affected my viewership
give it a rating one to ten
uh i'll let you know when i finish it
heil hitler
what the [ __ ]
you're throwing us under the bus
all right play with fire we're watching
oh people want us to talk about triller
now thank you dan
i feel like it's more of a friday topic
yeah it feels like a friday thing
oh wait
oh my god
by the time we actually roll around to
talking about we're gonna have like a
whole dossier like a whole 10 hour
because we keep adding [ __ ] to it
because there was the they're being sued
by two rappers that made a show for them
that they never paid
right and then they're at
and then yeah all the influencer stuff
too yeah and then they ripped off a
bunch of block creators
who they made all these promises to that
they just peace out on
which is very much ryan kavanaugh's
you know
ammo yo trailer
dude p diddy even made a video
condemning
you know
trailer p diddy ladies and gentlemen
watch the [ __ ] out
right
here it is
a little bit loud oh
good thank you
you know having an r b conversation
um
something i wanted to clarify um when me
and jd were talking about verses
um i mistakenly said verses instead of
triller
so to clarify it we're not [ __ ] with
trilla
until they take care of 10
and swiss for verses
nobody [ __ ] with trilla
until they take care
of 10 and swiss for verses because tim
is swiss
is versus
so am i being clear
absolutely crystal clear my favorite
we're not [ __ ] he did it
you know he just put it out he just
declared it man
nobody's [ __ ] with triller
period nobody [ __ ] with trilla
yeah they got they got this uh they
bought uh a freestyle
show from these guys
swizz beatz and timbaland
they sold the rights of the show to
triller
and then this is great this is so kev
kev listen to this
swizz and tiller agreed to sell versus a
trailer but they say triller defaulted
on the deal after only two payments
then swizz and timber timbaland say they
settled with triller after the initial
default
but then they say triller paid the same
as but played the same game as before
they made one installment and then
pieced out again
so these guys
they were supposed to pay them 28
million
i would call that uh fraud absolutely
so they go okay we'll pay you 28 million
in some installments and then so they
give them two payments and peace out and
then they sue them again
come to a new judgment new settlement
and then they [ __ ] peace out again
what a piece of [ __ ] bro
dude ryan cavanaugh is such a piece of
[ __ ]
you guys know about him
go to google ryan
ryan uh kavanaugh go to google and type
in the name
yeah right ryan
cavanaugh
yeah go check him out let's see oh and
then it came up anyways
oh oh man oh i guess oh my god
because wait forbes has an article above
ours that doesn't even make sense
where do you see that that's the only
reason i came what is this forbes
profile let me see what this is
one billion you know this is propaganda
you're not worth [ __ ] idiot
too much wine sorry
well some puff piece how do you get this
here
you must be paying a lot of money to seo
this [ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah probably
ooh ryan cavanagh natalie portman
i wonder what that's about i would read
up on that that shit's pretty gnarly
i have an inappropriate relationship
with a 14 year old natalie portman wait
ryan kavanagh look alike okay that's
fascinating okay so then there's our
website looks like harvey weinstein
right this is fun let's see what else
right kavanagh
uh
does ryan kavanagh
hey look
does this does rank heaven i'll look
alike that's very powerful
i love you proved it
teddy fresh
uh teeth whitening kit [ __ ] his
teeth are so yellow people look at him
and then they go they're going
immediately like i gotta get that taken
care of dude you're uh you're busted
dude
this is sick
yeah let's see ryan cavanaugh look alike
so i would probably go then to this
website
which has all the information you'll
need
right love
that's it all of it
that's true
i just uh i was curious
incognito browser here so no search
history you know okay sure because
ryan
reynolds oh interesting okay
oh
okay now that that's an important
question it's picking up well let's
click that
okay okay so interesting interesting
let's take a look at this
so it turns out they do look similar
according to this website we just found
i'm going to go ahead and accept cookies
on this site just kidding it's my
website it's a public service okay
yeah oh you know what we should get the
video of puffy on here love he says
nobody [ __ ] with trailer
yeah yeah yeah
until my boy gets paid what's this video
about it ryan cavanaugh is a force
i thought ryan was talking to the third
person there
he's talking about himself brian
cavanaugh is a force of nature it shows
him and then shows
him again it's just oh right there it
says harvey w i guess that's true
that's true
yeah there's him and there he is again
what what is this editing it doesn't
make any sense
it's one of the first rules they teach
in film schools don't do jump cuts
right jump pets are lame
yes so this is ryan kavkav
my favorite thing guys don't ever forget
he failed the he promised one million to
habitats with humanity and then bailed
he gave him 35 000 instead of a million
after they've called him out what a guy
why did he do that
that's like less than five percent
if only he got that five percent let's
think of how to dig ourselves out of
this fraud
all right so let's talk about him
ripping off black creators while we're
at it
taylor lorenz wrote an article about how
triller made financial promises to black
creators but never paid them
here's the article
yeah
a tick tock rival i love that like they
don't even get the name in the headline
because they're just so [ __ ] obscure
who
tick tock rival
yeah
they promised black creators millions of
dollars and now some of them are deep in
debt i was gonna put
its name recruiting talent with lavish
perks now dozens of influencers are
struggling to get paid
we were made to look like fools one
creator said
i'll summarize it for you um
each trader in the program would earn
money along with equity and triller so
equity and trailer how much is that
going to be worth do you think
that's a good question what what's zero
percent of zero or what's uh 10 of zero
the financial pledge to creators was 14
million dollars in fact they even put
out a [ __ ] press release about it
was this before or after the press
release accusing me of copyright
infringement
trailer awards one million contract
worth of 14 million to black creators
you know what i learned about ryan
kavanagh he loves the good headlines
hates the follow-through on the pledge
yeah
you know the easy part
good
the actual doing
difficult
here it is from trailer themselves 300
creators will each receive 4 000 per
month in cash and equity for 12 months
to create content across trailers
platform
largest transfer of value to black
creators at one time i mean dude it's 14
million dollars you're not you're not
solving an equity
they literally wrote for 15 million
the largest transfer of value to black
creators at one time
dude you're not abraham lincoln bro
you're just trying to get people on your
on your [ __ ] platform
that this this is such a an insane thing
to write
holy [ __ ]
that is embarrassing man
four scores and ten years ago
ryan kavanagh pledged 14 million to
black creators
crime was ended that day
and soon after barack obama became
president
um by the way did you guys get does this
make you uncomfy part of the deal
was that the black creators would get
deals with
popeyes mean specifically they include
they said we're going to get these black
creators and get them popeye's deals
and didn't right no no they didn't
they didn't but i'm just saying i mean
like could you have got something other
than [ __ ] like fried chicken it just
seems like it just makes me a little
uncomfortable yeah
you know
that's true
thank you that's an old one
i don't even know what that is oh it's
from from the weird like ladies that
speak to angels and they were like
doing this all the time i forget the
full context that is so true
that's true
yeah so people are you guys agree right
i mean he's just a little weird of all
the companies in the world you got to
have them selling fried chicken i mean
that's just kind of a little nuts
yes
and that was the only one like that was
that no there was two lists in the press
release it was popeyes and actually [ __ ]
can you send the press lisa and i uh oh
here i've got i've got my doc it was
popeyes and
this other company called
um
oh
[ __ ] where is it popeye's in hallmark
mahogany
old man
so
pretty interesting
little sauce
yeah so each creator yadda yadda yadda
he's saving he's basically solving
inequity
the biggest transfer of wealth of all
time is basically reparation yeah this
is
he's he saw the government dragging its
feet for the last 200 years and was like
no no longer
thank you prolapse penguin for the 20
gifted paralyzed penguin thank you for
the good thank you again thank
you year after triller began recruiting
black talent its payments to creator
have been non-existent
according to interviews with more than
two dozen creators
talent managers and former company staff
many of whom spoke to the washington
post
trailer in the recent years has been
trying to recruit big graders to come
over to the app by giving them big
paydays along with other lavish kids for
example i remember this
charlie dimigio got a rolls royce with a
license plate that says triller i mean
change the license plate obviously
probably sell the car too
can you imagine that's her first car
probably
driller
yeah so um
what's kind of crazy is that a lot of
these creators because
through some research we've we found
some and
talked to some behind the scenes
these were kind of like small medium
medium-sized creators who weren't
necessarily making a comfortable
reliable living from social media
so when they're promised four thousand
dollars a month for a year
that's money that they need
essentially to be able to do social
media full time
and so he promised this to them
and then ghosted them
or really [ __ ] their lives up
who wants me to take their money
hold on black creators were promised 4
000 a month with half of it coming in
equity bro how cheap are you
come on bro stop it
cheap ass in june some creators received
one month's payment in july some
creators began receiving back payment
for previous months
some creators were asked to sign an
agreement committing to confidentiality
to receive their pay
or risk forfeiture of all
equity considerations wait do don't we
have videos of people
talking about it
of the black creators talking about it
uh yes here let's watch these because
these are
these are better let's take it from
what's up y'all so i was one of the 100
black creators that was taken advantage
of lied to and manipulated by triller
the washington post just released an
article talking about the situation and
triller has still not paid hundreds of
creators
black creators matter of fact
when we started this partnership with
triller there was no official contract
yet but we were still obligated to post
or we would be kicked out of the program
all of us thought this was going to be a
great opportunity for us because
consistent income in the social media
industry is very rare and we were
desperate for the money at the time many
creators planned their bills around this
but due to triller being late with
payment almost 20 days after they were
supposed to pay some creators got
evicted from their apartments
my friend lost a loved one during the
program but the trailer team told him he
was still obligated to post even though
he was grieving
besides the money there was no support
for black creators it really just felt
like a pr stunt
what's up y'all there you have it i love
that he goes bro who here's
ryan cavanaugh probably personally i
know just [ __ ]
make a make a video at the casket dude
people love that
is it open casket good opportunity for
content
here's another one
of a guy no those i think those are just
links to their
tick tocks some of the creators
okay that was the only one that he was
like directly addressing it
was that the only guy who spoke about it
publicly
what about most of them are laying low
because they're still trying to get paid
and in fact once the article came out uh
apparently
suddenly they found the money to uh to
make good on a lot of this so yeah that
was thankfully some of them are getting
uh paid that was the interesting thing
once the washington post started
sniffing around about it all of a sudden
everyone magically got paid right which
is why
ultimately we were planning on doing
like a big piece and talking to people
about it and stuff but
i think they all got paid and don't want
to rock the boat which is fair i get it
yeah or some people said they would come
on but i think because they got paid it
was just you know they were willing to
come on but they they weren't really
able to say bad things about triller
which in a conversation with you i think
would have that's
difficult
[Music]
i just want their fair opinion
and if they're in on a non-disclosure
agreement under a settlement i don't
think that's a fair opinion
as let's see as washington post started
releasing the story creators said that
they started to receive notifications
from trailer that the payments
had been deposited there you go
one creator who had been seeking payment
for a deal with triller tv for over a
year magically received their payment
on top of the monthly payments trailer
would feed the creators brand deals
from popeyes
i didn't
trivian disqualifying creators who
didn't produce the required post some
creators said they were kicked out for
what they viewed as minor infractions
such as not adhering perfectly to the
posting schedule or not completing the
hallmark and popeye's promotions
okay whatever yeah so [ __ ] driller and
short
and uh
ron kavanaugh is a giant douche force of
nature
or
yeah as he said about himself a force of
nature right all right now we've talked
about every [ __ ] thing in this
document pretty right i don't think i
left anything out
i think we did it
mom and dad an apple pie
shirt
the swedish chef yeah the sweetest chef
huh the muppet the swedish chef no i
know what you're saying what uh
i have like a vague man what are we
dealing with here
i was hoping to just get you to sing it
like the swedish chef oh why i don't do
this swedish chef voice
it's not my whale house
everybody can do the sweetest chef
in the mirror why did what would you ask
me what did you expect to be able to
pick up from that sorry love but
you're right
that is very offensive to me actually
yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] up bro that's [ __ ]
up bro
swedish chef is a [ __ ] icon i don't i
don't i don't know why you found it
yeah up there with the greats yeah
called
i'll close out with this one because
this is the types of videos i used to
make before i even put my face on screen
i know you guys i played this for you
guys recently but oh let me like my own
video
if not me then who
if not now then when
um
this is my this is all kinds of video i
used to make mom and dad and apple pie
baseball games and picnics in july
fireworks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's america to me
[Music]
open arms and willingness giving just to
help
[Applause]
like it is just redlining over here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
respect for him throughout our history
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my boys straight up dead
500 something you have to protect no one
gives a [ __ ] about you bro
yeah there you go guys there is uh
some of my old work for you to
enjoy right ethan well we'll be back on
wednesday sure covered a lot of ground
here today i hope you guys had a good
old time rest in peace andrew tate i
will miss making content about you man
oh the meat canyon video yeah i'll watch
that sorry i didn't want to watch that
oh my god it's short it's short it's
like only two minutes
it's your girl yeah love me canyon he's
a good he's a friend good dude
funny
talented dude
uh here it is it's only three minutes so
we can enjoy it right
gentlemen we've had success with phase
one
expensive cars
money classic tate w
and most importantly sorry
cam just tossed me women we do begin
their [ __ ]
that's so good i feel like we gotta post
this
can you post this to our socials sure
yeah i just posted the other mimi did
posted later it's so funny
it's gonna send it it's so stupid but
it's so funny
yeah it's good it's just i think it
would really bother his fans
for some reason
yeah so here's meat canyon anyway
but
it's time now for phase two of our
journey
and that gentleman is
[Music]
um
me get a smoke off your cigar
[Music]
yeah oh here take that yeah put that in
your mouth okay i will
oh [ __ ] oh
bled i smoke out oh i will
[Music]
but not as sweet as you
baby i don't think i have a mirror eh
oh wait yeah here's one
i'm a real toy
did he just give birth
what's going on lads what's the problem
you like
you gave birth that's
that's like a a woman thing right
giving birth is like
a woman thing
yo
this is suss
one of you guys are female or a woman
or something i
guys
i'm not a female
if anything
he's the female
what are you talking about
you are the one calling me baby the
whole time which is classically a female
blue
fine
let's prove who's a man right now then
fine
they're fighting like grabs
[Music]
no oh
is that aiden ross i thought that was
yeah
i know this is
kyle yeah
i loved him going for no kyle i'll stand
up [ __ ] because people don't people
don't [ __ ] with now for some reason
because i guess they have crazy fans but
man those guys stuck
rip it dart
i'm gonna rip a dart
i'm gonna go rip a dart money
money
what did he say
what did you say little baby
girls should wear leashes like the dogs
they are oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah so
uh you guys should check out me canyon
if you're not subscribed
he basically just makes these little
vignettes
uh and they're all great
they're all great so
shout out meat canyon
good stuff huh look at this [ __ ] guy
bro
i think you for missed a little bit of
sky there cam yeah i was that was the
liquify i'll fix it right now
all right guys thanks for watching we'll
see you on wednesday okay have a great
week we love you be strong
you know
keep pushing
oh
we got four episodes this week
from the music i'm bringing in
so let's do this
[Music]
whose songs i want
[Music]
you